Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die Deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur fünften Ausgabe, in dieser kleinen Gesprächsserie, wo es geht um Forschung, wo es geht um Bildung und wo wir versuchen ein paar Horizonte aufzuzeigen, und ein wenig den Status quo zu hinterfragen und auch ein wenig Anleitung zu geben, für Wissenschaftler, angehende Wissenschaftler und Leute, die sich in irgendeiner Form auch in diesem Bereich bewegen. Ein wichtiger Teil der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit ist die Wissenschaftskommunikation und das auf sehr vielfältigen Ebenen und darum soll es heute gehen. Und dazu begrüße ich Onur Güntürkün. Hallo, willkommen bei Forschergeist.
Hallo.
Schön, dass wir heute hier zusammen sprechen können. Vielleicht müssen wir erst einmal ein bisschen über Sie erzählen. Sie sind Wissenschaftler, im Bereich der Biopsychologie. Ganz konkret in Bochum, an der Universität, wenn ich es richtig erinnere, Institut für kognitive Neurowissenschaft. Ist das die richtige Übersetzung?
Das ist die richtige Übersetzung. Die ist in der Fakultät für Psychologie.
Ja, und was umfasst denn dieser Bereich im wesentlichen?
Die kognitive Neurowissenschaft versucht, im Grunde zu verstehen, wie Denken funktioniert. Also wir denken, wir erinnern, wir fühlen, wir planen und all das passiert in unserem Kopf. Das passiert in unseren Gedanken. Und ich und viele andere Leute möchten eigentlich verstehen, wie funktioniert das, was sind die Gesetze dieses Denkens, wie kommt es, dass ich mich erinnern kann. Aber auch wie kommt es, dass ich vergesse. Was passiert im Gehirn, wenn all diese Dinge passieren. Das ist im Kurzen gesagt, die kognitive Naturwissenschaft. Das beste was man machen kann, finde ich.
Wie lange wird denn daran schon so in der Form geforscht?
Das ist eine schwierige Frage, weil es immer ganz schwierig ist, den Anfang von etwas zu bestimmen. Letztendlich muss man sagen, vor ungefähr vor 100 Jahren hat sich die Hirnforschung wirklich als ein eigener Forschungszweig so ganz langsam herauskristallisiert. Dass man das wirklich als etwas ganz was eigenständiges ansah, ist vielleicht 50 Jahre her. Und dass man dann anfing, wirklich am Denken selbst, also an den kognitiven Prozessen im Detail zu forschen, ist natürlich noch viel weniger lange her. Ich schätze mal 30-40 Jahre. Natürlich gab es dann immer Leute, die dazu etwas gesagt oder geschrieben haben, aber das wirklich das Denken selbst zu einem Thema der Hirnforschung, die wiederum ein eigenes Gebiet wurde, das ist vielleicht 40 Jahre her.
Und das ist interessanterweise in der Psychologie einsortiert und nicht etwa in der Biologie oder überschneidet sich das so sehr, dass man das gar nicht unterscheiden kann?
Ich glaube nicht, dass man das wirklich so unterscheiden kann. Also die Psychologen machen dazu wahrscheinlich den größten Beitrag. Allein von der sozusagen der Menschenzahl, die daran arbeitet. Wenn man die so in Kästchen mit Psychologie, Biologie, Medizin unterscheiden möchte, dann wäre das Kästchen Psychologie wahrscheinlich das größte. Aber Neurowissenschaftler sind ja eigentlich per se interdisziplinär. Also nur um das zu illustrieren, ich hatte schon mal einen Doktoranden, der war Raumfahrtingenieur zum Beispiel. In meinem Labor arbeiten alle möglichen jungen Menschen, und ich weiß noch nicht mal, was die für einen Abschluss haben. Ich glaube zwei sind Biochemiker, einer ist Biologe, es gibt jemanden aus der Medizin, der ist aber mittlerweile schon wieder weg, ein toller Typ gewesen. Und ist es immer noch. Jede Menge Psychologen, also eine bunte Mixtur von allem. Die Neurowissenschaft selbst ist also halt wirklich etwas Neues. Was interdisziplinär ist und die kognitive Neurowissenschaft hat diesen Flavour von mehr Denken, mehr Verhaltensforschung, was die Psychologen sehr stark macht, aber es ist natürlich nach wie vor interdisziplinär.
Was hat Sie denn zu dem Thema geführt? Vielleicht können wir ja mal ein bisschen zurückblättern, wie ging es überhaupt los mit Ihrem Weg in die Wissenschaft? Was stand denn da am Anfang?
Ich glaube, ich habe nie etwas anderes gemacht. Ich habe als kleines Kind so Musikkassettenschachteln von meiner älteren Schwester geraubt, dann die Kassetten raus genommen, den Karton raus genommen, und dann so kleine Kartonlabyrinthe gebaut da drinnen, die passten ganz wunderbar rein. Dann Käfer gesammelt und versucht herauszukriegen, wie die lernen, aus diesem Labyrinth wieder raus zu kommen. Ich habe Fische konditioniert, ich habe alles mögliche gemacht. Ich habe im wesentlichen nie etwas anderes gemacht, als das, was ich jetzt mache. Ich mache es jetzt natürlich viel professioneller, mit viel mehr Geld, zielgerichteter, ich lerne aus der Literatur usw. Ich bin ein Profi. Und damals war ich einfach nur ein Kind. Aber ich war die gleiche Person, mit den gleichen Interessen. Es gab eigentlich in meinem Leben keinen echten Nullpunkt.
Außer den eigentlichen Nullpunkt.
Außer dem eigentlichen Nullpunkt. Aber sozusagen bezüglich des geistigen Interesses kann ich mich an wirklich keinen echten Nullpunkt erinnern.
Also sprich der Wunsch wissenschaftlich zu arbeiten, war ohnehin schon immer da, aber irgendwann muss sich das ja auch in einem selbst institutionalisieren, dass man sagt, o. k. das ist jetzt wirklich auch das, was ich primär im wesentlichen machen will und nicht nur so als ausuferndes Hobby.
Also es gibt so eine kleine Berufsmarke, die mein Vater mal für mich gemacht hat, darauf steht Privatdetektiv. Also ganz offensichtlich, da war ich vier Jahre alt, gab es doch mal eine Zeit vor dem Forscher, da wollte ich Privatdetektiv werden. Ich gucke ab und zu dieses Ding an und kann es nicht fassen, dass mich damals das interessiert hat, aber so war es wohl. Später habe ich Visitenkarten gemacht, da stand immer Paläontologe drauf, das war die übliche Dinosaurierbegeisterung. Andere Visitenkarten habe ich dann später nicht gemacht, auf der Visitenkarte, die ich jetzt habe steht kognitive Neurowissenschaft drauf und das beschreibt es auch ziemlich gut. Also bis auf diese Detektiv-Umwege, die ich damals als vierjähriger offensichtlich hatte, hatte ich immer schon dieses Faible für Wissenschaft.
Also so undetektivisch ist es ja jetzt auch nicht diese Arbeit.
Absolut. Man sucht jetzt nicht unbedingt den Mörder oder so. Aber man versucht die Wahrheit heraus zu bekommen. Insofern ja, passt doch, stimmt.
Spuren analysieren.
Absolut. Da habe ich so noch gar nicht dran gedacht.
Theorien aufbauen.
Vielleicht sollte ich diese kleine Identitätsmarke doch mal über den Schreibtisch hängen.
Ja, also ich finde das jetzt gar nicht so unpassend. War es denn einfach, den Weg in die Wissenschaft zu finden? Standen dem irgendwelche Hindernisse im Weg?
Natürlich, es stehen immer für alles jede Menge Hindernisse im Weg. Im Nachhinein sieht es dann immer natürlich geradliniger aus, als es ist. Man konstruiert sich ja sein Leben als einen geradlinigen Plan, den man von Anfang an hatte. Und diesen Plan habe ich natürlich in meinem erinnern auch. Wenn ich wirklich mal realistisch in mein Leben schaue, war dieser Wunsch immer sehr stark da, aber ich wusste nicht, erstens ob ich das kann, ob das klappt, also ich hatte einen brennenden Wunsch in mir zu promovieren während des Studiums, während des Hauptstudiums. Meine Freundin, meine jetzige Frau hat auf dem Silbertablett mehrere Promotionsmöglichkeiten angeboten bekommen. Sie ist etwas älter als ich, insofern war das bei ihr eher dran. Und ich konnte es gar nicht fassen, dass sie ernsthaft darüber nachdachte, alle Angebote abzuschlagen, weil für mich war das der absolute Traum. Und insofern habe ich mich nach dem Diplom auch beworben und war überglücklich, als ich genau dort, wo ich gerne arbeiten wollte, ein Angebot bekam. Also da hatte ich das Gefühl, das war vielleicht eins der überragendsten Glücksgefühle in meinem professionellen Leben, dieses Angebot. Und danach wollte ich eigentlich immer unbedingt in der Wissenschaft bleiben. Ich hatte keine klare Vorstellung, dass ich Professor werde oder so etwas, aber ich wollte Wissenschaft machen. Nun ist natürlich, wenn man einmal im Wissenschaftsbetrieb ist, sind die Gesetzmäßigkeiten ziemlich klar festgelegt, gerade in einem Land wie Deutschland, man wird Professor oder arbeitslos. Und ich bin Professor geworden.
Welches Studium war denn das?
Psychologie.
Ach so. O. k., also das war im Prinzip schon alles so auf dem Weg?
Ja.
Warum nimmt man denn dann… Also was ist denn so das Urinteresse daran, Psychologie als Studium zu wählen? Ich meine, da war ja sicherlich jetzt diese Neurowissenschaft so am Anfang noch gar nicht da.
Also das Wort Neurobiologie gab es damals noch gar nicht, als ich mich für Psychologie entschieden habe. Ich war damals in der Türkei im Gymnasium, wir hatten Psychologie als Unterrichtsfach und wir hatten einen, im Nachhinein gesehen, großartiges Buch, als Kind kann man das ja nicht wirklich beurteilen, ob das jetzt ein gutes Schulbuch ist, ist das ein schlechtes, alle Schulbücher sind so ein bisschen ätzend, weil man sie auswendig lernen muss, aber im Nachhinein muss ich sagen, dass war ein tolles Buch. Das war experimentelle Psychologie, es war all das drin, was mich faszinierte. Wie funktioniert Verhalten, wie lernt man, wie erinnert man sich, alles war drin. Und ich dachte Psychologie, das ist es. Später habe ich gedacht, Medizin könnte es auch sein und in der Türkei im Abitur habe ich dann angefangen, zu lesen. Und stellte fest, dass die UNO oder die WHO, ich weiß nicht mehr so genau, das Medizinstudium in der Türkei als ziemlich gut mal beschrieben hatte. Also da hatte ich Vertrauen drin. Psychologie hatte ich gehört, aber nichts darüber gelesen, dass es nicht so besonders gut ist, das Psychologiestudium in der Türkei. Zwischen diesen zwei Optionen musste ich wählen. Ich dachte, das sind meine zwei Straßen, zu dem was damals noch gar keinen Namen hatte, also irgendetwas mit Gehirn. Und mit Verhalten und mit Denken. Und dann passierte folgendes, Psychologie im Ausland, Medizin in der Türkei, das war der Plan. Mein Vater ist Arzt, kam mittags öfter nach Hause, und brachte diese furchtbaren Medizinzeitschriften mit, in denen dann diese bunten Bilder mit Geschwüren und aufgeplatzten Wunden und abgehackten irgendwas… Und ich konnte mir diese Bilder nicht angucken, und die lagen auf dem Wohnzimmertisch. Ich weiß noch genau, mein Vater mit Krawatte kam rein, schmiss dann diese Zeitschriften auf den Wohnzimmertisch, der glatt und groß war, es rutschte auf dem Wohnzimmertisch aus, spreizte sich aus und dieser Wohnzimmertisch war dann irgendwie der Nogo-Bereich für mich. Und da habe ich gedacht, nein ich kann mir noch nicht einmal die Bilder angucken, wie soll ich das studieren. Geht gar nicht. Und damit war der Plan klar, ich muss die Türkei verlassen. Ich will Psychologie studieren. Aber nicht in der Türkei. Da ich schon in der, damals hieß es Volksschule, in der Grundschule in Deutschland gewesen war, einige Jahre, konnte ich gut Deutsch und ich dachte, Deutschland das ist es. Und so bin ich nach Deutschland gekommen.
O. k., also Sie sind in der Türkei geboren worden, dann gab es eine Zeit in Deutschland und dann wieder in der Türkei und dann war letzten Endes das Psychologiestudium quasi dann der Anlass, noch mal einen weiteren Wechsel zu machen.
Exakt. Die Psychologie ist schuld.
O. k., die Psychologie ist schuld. Ja, woran haben Sie denn dann geforscht? Also es hatte alles ganz gut geklappt, Psychologiestudium, dann gab es die Möglichkeit zu promovieren, und irgendwann wurde auch eine Professorenstelle, das war dann auch schon in Bochum?
Also die erste Professur war tatsächlich in Bochum. Ich habe Bochum dann verlassen für erst Paris, dann San Diego, dann Konstanz und dann in Konstanz habe ich habilitiert und dann bewirbt man sich halt auf alles, was sich geradezu bewegt, was halbwegs passt. Und das war zufällig dann wieder Bochum, also die Stadt, in der ich sowohl studiert, als auch promoviert habe. Und dann haben meine Frau und ich eine Weile überlegt, ob es eine gute Idee ist, zurückzukehren. Es ist prinzipiell immer in der Regel eine schlechte Idee zurückzukehren. In diesem Fall war es aber eine Ausnahme. Es war eine verdammt gute Idee. Und ich bin immer noch in Bochum. Und ich hatte verschiedenste Möglichkeiten, weg zu gehen, aber es hat mir immer in Bochum so gut gefallen, dass ich da geblieben bin und das auf gar keinen Fall bereue. Das ist eine tolle Stadt, um Wissenschaft zu machen.
Ich würde es vielleicht sonst gar nicht ansprechen, aber ich hatte jetzt gerade in der letzten Ausgabe von Forschergeist, habe ich mit Suhat Yilmaz gesprochen, der Name sagt Ihnen sicherlich was, der für Talentförderung an der Westfälischen Hochschule da interessante Arbeit macht und explizit auch gerade für diese Region da, ich sage mal, viele Probleme überwindet, die insbesondere, aber nicht nur, Einsteiger aus dem Ausland, auch aus der Türkei haben. Waren das für Sie auch Probleme, die eine Rolle gespielt haben?
Nein. Weil nicht das Ausland die Rolle spielt, sondern die sozioökonomische Schicht von der man kommt. Der akademische Hintergrund. Es ist ziemlich egal, ob Sie aus Afghanistan kommen oder nicht. Wenn Sie aus einer akademischen Familie kommen, sind Sie in allen Akademien dieser Welt sehr schnell zu Hause. Aber wenn Sie aus dem katholischen Oberbayern kommen und seit Generationen hat keiner dort eine etwas höhere Schule besucht, dann haben Sie durchaus ein ähnliches Problem, wie jemand, der aus dem Ausland kommt, aber keinen akademischen Hintergrund hat. Sie haben natürlich weniger Sprachprobleme, das macht das Problem wesentlich stärker. Wenn Sie dann aus dem Ausland kommen. Die Sprachprobleme hatte ich nicht, meine Eltern waren Akademiker. Natürlich gab es jede Menge Probleme, aber ich glaube nicht, das waren Probleme die spezifisch waren für mich. Ich glaube, der eigentliche Punkt ist der, die akademische Welt hat Tausende von niemals ausgesprochenen Codes, wie schreibe ich einen Brief, wie bewerbe ich mich, wie verhalte ich mich in einer bestimmten Situation, was ist eine Chance für mich und was ist definitiv keine Chance. Und ich sollte nicht so tun, als ob ich sie ergreifen wollte. Das sind ganz viele Dinge, die lernt man natürlich in einem bestimmten Umfeld. Man hat auch Eltern, die man fragen kann oder man hat Freunde der Eltern, die man fragen kann und die können ein durchaus auch unterstützen. Und wenn dieses ganze Umfeld fehlt, dann kann es sein, dass man dann anfängt, von Dingen zu träumen, für die man sich dann aber anders verhalten müsste, um sie zu erreichen. Und so bleiben diese Träume dann leere Träume. Und deshalb ist es glaube ich ganz ganz wichtig, dass das was in Münster passiert, aber auch in Duisburg, Essen und an mehr und mehr Universität passiert, dass man Menschen sehr früh, sowohl an der Universität, aber auch schon viel früher begleitet und das, was einem fehlt, in dem eigenen sozialen Umfeld Schwerpunkt Migrantenumfeld, aber auch durchaus auch jenseits des Migrantenumfeldes, dass man diesen Menschen hilft, Ihnen zu sagen, du hast eine Chance. Du machst es am besten soundso. Lies das, tu das. Pass auf, dieser Person muss du jetzt einen Brief schreiben, und zwar am besten soundso. Ich möchte Ihnen ein Beispiel geben, das ich wahnsinnig traurig finde. Ich war vor einigen Jahren in der Kinder Universität in unserer Uni zugange. Das ist aller zwei Jahre, da kommen im größten Hörsaal ich glaube über 2000 Kinder rein, so im Alter 7-9-10 Jahre. Und dann erzählen Wissenschaftler von ihrer Forschung und das sollen sie natürlich möglichst kindgerecht tun. Macht wahnsinnigen Spaß, die Kinder sind begeistert, und man erzählt irgendetwas, 1000 Hände gehen in die Höhe, ich will sagen, ich will sagen, ich will sagen usw. Ich saß in einer Ecke, wo eine Schulklasse war und es war ganz offensichtlich, da waren drei türkische Jungs. Und alle anderen sahen zumindest nicht türkisch aus. Und es war das übliche Tohuwabohu. Frau Müller, der hat mir mein Mitschreibmäppchen weggenommen usw. und so fort. Alle Kinder gleich. Und ich drehte mich zu ihnen um und fragte, ist das toll hier und alle schrien, ja. Ich glaube die waren ungefähr acht. Und dann rief ich denen zu, und wenn ihr dann Abitur macht, wollt ihr dann zu uns an die Uni kommen? Alle Kinder, bis auf diese drei türkischen Kinder schrien, ja. Und diese drei türkischen Kinder guckten betroffen. Achtjährige Kinder, die sich akademisch aufgegeben hatten. Das darf nicht sein. Das darf auf gar keinen Fall sein. Und so früh wird Menschen klargemacht, dass sie in einer Gesellschaft, zumindest in bestimmten Bereichen, keine Chancen haben. Und ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, wo wir rein müssen. Wo wir viel mehr investieren müssen. Und ich nehme dieses Wort Investitionen sehr bewusst in den Mund, es ist tatsächlich eine Investitionen. Es ist eine Investition in diese Gesellschaft, die sozial extrem wichtig ist, die menschlich extrem wichtig ist, die aber letztendlich sich auch monetär Auszeit für dieses Land.
Was denken Sie denn, wer diesen Kindern diese Vision genommen hat oder nicht geboten hat?
Ich glaube, sie wachsen auf, in einem Umfeld, wo diese Welt gar nicht existiert. Und da diese Welt nicht existiert, gibt es natürlich dann auch die Interpretation, warum diese Welt nicht existiert. Wir sind Türken, uns gibt doch keiner was. Was teilweise richtig ist, aber was teilweise dann eben richtig beobachtet ist, aber falsch bezüglich der Kausalmechanismen nicht immer richtig interpretiert worden ist. Meine Frau und ich reden dann öfter darüber, was machen wir nach der Rente, und es gibt 1000 Dinge, die man dann nach der Rente macht. Wahrscheinlich machen wir die Dinge dann doch ganz anders, als wir sie uns vornehmen… Aber eine von diesen Dingen, die wir uns immer wieder vornehmen ist, wir machen jetzt endlich mal wieder was richtig nützliches. Wir gehen in die Grundschulen und schnappen uns ein paar Kinder und hoffen, dass uns die Grundschuldirektorinnen und -direktoren auch wirklich machen lassen und machen dann Hausaufgabenbetreuung und solche Sachen. Wir gehen dann einfach hin und sagen, hier bin ich und wir würden gerne, was weiß ich, eine Reihe von Kindern Patenonkel oder Patentante von denen sein. Und die einfach ein bisschen durchs Leben begleiten. Und vielleicht ein kleines bisschen das kompensieren, was diesen Kindern in ihrem sozialen Umfeld fehlt. Diesen Kindern fehlt fast nie Liebe, manchmal ja, aber fast nie, sondern wirklich das Händchen, wie mache ich das. Und die Hoffnung am Leben erhalten, aber eben mit den entsprechenden Verhaltensmechanismen unterfüttern.
Um jetzt mal ein bisschen auf den eigentlichen Themenbereich zu kommen, wenn man jetzt so seine wissenschaftliche Karriere aufbaut und anfängt, da werden Sie sicherlich auch noch gut daran erinnern, was die ersten Schwierigkeiten waren, da ist ja dann auch erst mal alles neu. Also ich meine, man hat da zwar das Studium in irgendeiner Form schon kennengelernt, aber in dem Moment, wo man dann wirklich auf eigenen Füßen steht, und dann vielleicht eben auch noch so einen eigenen Professorenbereich betreuen muss, da gelten natürlich auf einmal andere Zwänge, man hat irgendwie auf der einen Seite mehr Freiheiten, aber dadurch entstehen ja dann auch auf einer anderen Art und Weise dann wieder mehr Verpflichtungen. Ist das etwas, was einem sozusagen in dem eigentlichen Forschergeist, den man so hat, so ein bisschen in die Quere kommt? Das organisatorische.
Ganz massiv. Es ist ein ganz wichtiger Teil des Lebens, denn das Forschen wollen ist das eine, das Forschen in einer Gruppe können ist das andere. Und man macht ja die ganzen verschiedenen Rollen durch. Man ist ja erst mal so der kleinste im Stall, man promoviert, man arbeitet an einem ganz kleinen Projekten, man fokussiert sich auf dieses ganz kleine Projekt. Dann gibt es den großen Meister, der kommt ab und zu vorbei und sagt irgendetwas positiv, negativ. Man fiebert der ersten Publikation entgegen. Man lernt dann ganz viele Verhaltensweisen, das worüber wir auch gerade gesprochen haben, aber spezifisch dann für den Wissenschaftsberuf, für den Beruf Wissenschaft. Und man wächst dann langsam aus dieser Rolle heraus, man ist dann Postdoc, man hat selber eine kleine Gruppe. Und als Postdoc ist es dann eben so, man kann noch der Illusion sich hingeben, man ist gleicher unter gleichen. Man ist halt nur ein bisschen älter, man weiß ein bisschen mehr, und die Leute hören einem zu. Aber man geht abends in die Kneipe und alle sind irgendwo gleich. Schon da ist es schon ein bisschen eine Illusion. Aber diese Illusion, die glaubt man dann noch ein bisschen. Spätestens dann, wenn man Professor wird, ist es für mich ganz wichtig gewesen, und das habe ich auch nicht besonders gut hingekriegt, aber ich habe es vielleicht halb hingekriegt, zu realisieren, dass man mehr und mehr nicht mehr Freund in einer Band ist, sondern dass man Chef ist. Ein Chef bedeutet, ich muss Dinge bewerten, ich muss sagen, dafür kann ich dir keine gute Note geben. Ich muss sagen, ich kann diesen Vertrag nicht verlängern. Ich muss sagen, ich muss leider diese Stelle dieser Person geben und nicht dir, weil… Das verträgt sich nicht mit der Rolle eines Freundes und eines Kameraden. Das geht nur, wenn man Chef ist. Und in diese Rolle hinein zu wachsen, dauert immer ein bisschen. Also bei mir und ich beobachte das auch bei vielen anderen Kollegen, es gibt sicherlich Kollegen, die können das viel besser hin, als ich es hingekriegt habe. Aber dieser Transitionsprozess ist etwas, was jeder glaube ich im Leben dann für sich alleine lernen muss. Und dann wird es immer differenzierter. Die Gruppe wird größer, es entstehen Fraktionen, wie schaff ich es Transparenz innerhalb der Gruppe herzustellen, wie schaffe ich es, dass jeder weiß, was jeder andere weiß. Wie entdecke ich, dass irgendwo ein Problem ist, jemand ist in einem Schneckenhäuschen und denkt die ganze Zeit jetzt jedoch mal mit mir. Aber er verhält sich nicht dementsprechend. Wie identifiziere ich diese Person. Wie kriege ich es hin, dass meine eigene enorme Überlastung, die mich wirklich an die Grenzen meiner eigenen Arbeitsfähigkeit bringt, dass ich die trotzdem noch in Übereinstimmung bringe mit den Bedarfen meiner Leute, die ja auch mit mir reden wollen. Mit mir reden müssen. Dass ich sie nicht ganz sich selbst überlassen. Und jeder hat da so seinen ganz eigenen Stil. Und jeder Stil passt optimal zu einigen jungen Menschen und passt überhaupt nicht zu einigen anderen Menschen. Ich bevorzuge die lange Leine. Ich bevorzuge, dass ich mit Menschen über Projekte spreche, ihnen aber nicht bis ins mikroskopische Detail sage, was sie machen müssen, wie sie es machen müssen und dann jeden Abend Bericht erstattet bekommen möchte. Das ist großartig für Leute wie mich. So war ich. Das ist eine Katastrophe für Menschen, die eben an dieser langen Leine zu Grunde gehen. Die viel engere Betreuung haben. Insofern ist es so, dass in jedem Labor es immer Menschen gibt, die unglücklich sind. Weil sie sagen, würde der Chef sich mal mehr um mich kümmern, dann wäre es besser. Und in einem anderen Labor haben sie die Leute, würde der Chef mir endlich mal Luft zum Atmen lassen, dann ginge es mir besser. Sie können es niemals recht machen. So ist das Leben. Sie können nur versuchen, die Dinge irgendwo in einem Mittelwert zu optimieren, aber Sie gehen immer leicht depressiv ins Bett, weil Sie denken, naja schon wieder heute nicht das geschafft, schon wieder nicht das gemacht, was du dir eigentlich vorgenommen hattest. Also so ein bisschen Depression ist o. k.
Aber im Prinzip haben wir ja schon die erste Ebene von Kommunikation. Nämlich die Kommunikation mit dem unmittelbaren Umfeld. Konkret jetzt hier mit Studenten, Mitarbeitern oder dann eben auch den gleicheren sozusagen auf Institutionsebene. Haben Sie da irgendetwas, weiß nicht, es gibt da jetzt sicherlich keine goldene Lösung, aber auf was sollte man sich denn, welchen Weg sollte man sich denn so einfinden. Also was sollte man sich klarmachen, dass man sich an der Stelle nicht selbst überlastet, indem man auch zu wenig delegiert und was muss kommuniziert werden, wie sollte man seine interne Kommunikation aufbauen, um dort besser forschen und arbeiten zu können?
Naja ich lerne ja immer noch. Ich kann nicht behaupten, dass ich... Also ich fühle mich jetzt halbwegs wohl, aber ich schraube ständig und immerfort genau an diesen Fragestellungen herum. Was bei mir im Labor ganz gut funktioniert ist, dass es einmal in der Woche eine Gesamtsitzung gibt, wo jeder etwas erzählt, was in der letzten Woche da war. Und das gilt genauso auch für mich. Also auch ich muss Rechenschaft ablegen. Ich kann nicht von meinen Leuten Rechenschaft verlangen, wenn ich sie dabei nicht auch ablegen. Und d.h. der Rechenschaftsbericht, also das hört sich anders an, aber jeder erzählt, was los war und jeder erzählt, was er so machen möchte und dann redet man über diese Dinge. Und daraus entsteht dann manchmal, o. k. das man sagt, das muss ich vertiefen, sollen wir uns denn heute um 16 Uhr treffen, dass wir diese Dinge mal 2 Stunden in Ruhe das durchdiskutieren können. Das zweite ist, dass ich mit meinem Postdocs, also mit den Leuten, die schon promoviert sind, die häufig auch kleine Gruppen innerhalb des Labors leiten, dass ich mich mit denen 1 Stunde in der Woche treffe und dann nur über Wissenschaft rede. Das nennt sich der Jourfix. Das ist ganz wichtig, denn diese Leute haben ja selbst auch Leitungsverantwortung zu übernehmen. Und da reden wir dann manchmal eben auch über schwierige Fälle. Da gibt es dann einen Doktoranden, der im Moment eben gegen die Wand gefahren ist mit seinem Projekt. Wie gehen wir damit um? Und wie können wir dann helfen? Wo sind sozusagen blöde gesagt, wer ist schuld daran. War die Planung schuld? Oder wo sind die Entscheidungen falsch getroffen worden usw.? Und auch, was ist die Zukunft. Was sind die längerfristigen Spuren an Wissenschaft, die wir beide machen sollen. Ganz wichtig ist, dass man delegieren kann. Ganz wichtig ist, dass man viele Dinge auch ins Sekretariat delegiert. Also bei mir ist es häufig so, dass wenn ich an meiner Sekretärin vorbei gehe, die schnappt mich dann und sagt, da 20 Unterschriften, das brauche ich jetzt, sonst komme ich hier nicht weiter. Und dann unterschreibe ich da zwanzigmal und dann sage ich jedes Mal, dann unterschreib du doch für mich, und dann sagt sie, nein es ist verboten, und dann unterschreibe ich zwanzigmal. Und dann geht es weiter. Und ich kann mich halt wirklich blind auf sie verlassen. Das sind die Dinge, wie ich sie eingerichtet habe. Das hört sich gut an, klappt ganz gut, fühlt sich gut an und trotzdem gibt es manchmal eben Dinge, die unschön sind. Und dann die Kommunikation mit meinen direkten Kolleginnen und Kollegen, innerhalb der Fakultät, innerhalb der Universität, das läuft vollkommen anders. Da kann ich nicht sagen, dass ich da jetzt auch wieder weiß, wie es geht. Ich kann nur sagen, wie ich es mache. Ich habe einmal gelernt, dass das Leben verdammt lang ist. Und wenn man eine Person so richtig auf die Füße tritt, das tut nicht gut. Wir haben ein sehr gutes Gedächtnis und wir begegnen uns ganz häufig im Leben. Und deshalb bin ich der Meinung, das Beste ist, man ist so transparent wie es geht, man raubt niemandem das Gesicht und man versucht, immer als Gruppe gemeinsam, Dinge zu beschließen. Und wenn jemand dagegen ist, dann überstimmt man ihn oder sie nicht einfach, sondern versucht sehr lange mit dieser Person zu reden, bis diese Person dann vielleicht selber sagt, ich bleibe bei meiner Meinung. Aber das ist kein Problem, wir stimmen jetzt ab, ich werde die Abstimmung verlieren, aber das ist kein großes Problem. Wir haben lange darüber gesprochen, ich bin nach wie vor vom Gegenteil überzeugt, aber so ist das Leben. D.h. das sind so Dinge, die ich zumindest so mache. Transparent sein, auch freigiebig sein und immer daran denken, dass ich dem Menschen immer wieder begegnen werde. Das klappt bei mir zumindest gut.
Ja das ist schon eine wichtige Erkenntnis. Am Anfang ist es ja noch sehr überraschend, wenn man so am Anfang von allem steht denkt man immer so, ach der hat mich geärgert, sehe ich nie wieder, mir doch egal und so, aber dann stellt man fest…
Ich sehe den immer wieder.
Nicht nur einmal, sondern eher so 10-100 Mal. Läuft man sich mal über den Weg. Also ich denke, das ist klar, auch irgendwie ein gutes Verhältnis zu den Menschen als solchen zu halten ist wichtig. Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil wir im Prinzip uns jetzt so aus einem inneren Kern der Kommunikation jetzt eigentlich an das Thema herantasten. Und es klar ist, dass das unmittelbare Umfeld zunächst einmal auch das unmittelbar wichtigste ist, aber sicherlich nicht das einzige, was wichtig ist, denn um jetzt auch die eigene Arbeit zu legitimieren, heißt es ja auch, man braucht auch den Zuspruch von anderen Institutionen, des eigenen Forschungsumfeldes, also der Universität oder Forschungseinrichtung, sowohl in den Hierarchien, als auch in, wie soll ich sagen, anderen Fakultäten, deren Kooperation man benötigt. Sicherlich lassen sich jetzt viele dieser Prinzipien, die wir schon besprochen haben, auch übertragen, aber ich denke an einem bestimmten Punkt kommen ja dann auch noch mal ganz andere Dinge dahin. Denn man muss sich auch selbst zeigen, muss sich auch selbst erklären, man muss auch klarmachen, wohin will ich, warum ist das alles relevant, was ich hier tue. Und macht sich dann so das nächste Türchen jetzt auf, so jetzt als Kommunikationsebene. Sind das jetzt schon die anderen Institute an der Universität, ist das schon ein anderes Kommunikationsprocedere, was man hier an den Tag legen muss?
Selbstverständlich. Deutschland bzw. das deutsche Universitätssystem marschiert in die richtige Richtung. Es ist mehr und mehr ein meritokratisches System, d.h. ein System, in dem die Leistung auch tatsächlich honoriert wird und es nicht so ist, dass man irgendwie große Ressourcen hat, bloß weil man der Schüler von dem großen Professor Müller oder dem großen Professor Meyer ist. So wie es früher war. Sondern jede Generation, jedes einzelne Individuum wird aufs Neue geprüft und hat eine neue eigene Chance. Und das bedeutet, die Leistung, die man zeigt, ist natürlich die Hauptvariable, die dabei zählt. Und die versuchen wir alle, zu bringen. Leistungen können ganz viele Facetten haben. Leistung hat immer eine Qualitätsvariable, immer. Es ist immer ein langer Disput, ob es auch eine Quantitätsvariable hat, wahrscheinlich hat es die auch immer, aber ich glaube, Qualität sticht in der Regel Quantität, obwohl die Beziehung komplex ist. Und dann muss man natürlich auch sich verkaufen, denn der Beruf des Wissenschaftlers ist ja auch ein Wissenschaftler, indem man quasi eine Ich-AG hat. Ich bin halt Onur Güntürkün hier auch unterwegs und verkaufe meine Ideen. Ich muss sie verkaufen, weil ich will Jobs, ich will Forschungsgelder, ich will Menschen davon überzeugen, dass es wichtig ist und ich möchte sie davon überzeugen, dass sie auch in eine ähnliche Richtung forschen. Und das bedeutet, ich kann nicht nur in meiner Höhle sitzen und gute Forschung machen, sondern ich muss raus aus meiner Höhle und ich muss dann den Menschen klarmachen, dass das ziemlich klasse ist, was ich da gerade mache. Dass es wirklich spannend ist. Weil das eine tiefe Frage bewegt. Und das muss ich kommunizieren können. Und das ist durchaus auch eine Gabe, aber es ist auch ganz viel Training. Es ist auch ganz viel Lernen dabei, das kommunizieren zu können. Und das ist Teil des Jobs. Und das vergessen, vor allen Dingen junge Leute manchmal, sie denken, ich habe eine gute Qualität abgeliefert, that's it, mehr muss ich nicht tun, aber die Leute müssen das auch wissen, dass man das gemacht hat. Deshalb versuche ich, den jungen Menschen bei mir im Labor immer auch ganz stark sie dahingehend zu beraten, was sie jetzt machen müssten. Also wir üben ihre Vorträge, wir üben ihre Präsentationen. Wir üben auch, so lächerlich es klingen mag, wie sie da stehen und das erzählen. Weil es ist so wichtig, dass auch hinzukriegen. Das hört sich blöd an, aber das ist wirklich wichtig.
Das hört sich überhaupt nicht blöd an. Ich finde, dass gerade in Deutschland gibt es einen Mangel an Präsentationskultur. Das ist hier so ein gesellschaftsinherentes Problem. Ich habe selber noch nicht so hundertprozentig herausgefunden, woran es denn eigentlich liegt, aber im Vergleich mit anderen Ländern, fällt es doch schnell auf, dass hier gerade das Präsentieren von eigenen Sachen irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ob es keinen guten Ruf hat oder ob es einfach als unwichtig angesehen wird, ich weiß nicht, wie Sie das sehen, wo es daran krankt, aber man könnte sich generell mehr Mühe machen. Wer hat nicht schon geächzt, gerade so im wissenschaftlichen Bereich ist es noch mal besonders verbreitet, so mit Text überladenen Folien, wo dann irgendwie lange Texte vorgelesen werden und es ist einfach so ein totaler Schnarcher. Man fragt sich immer so, ihr wisst es doch eigentlich besser und wenn ihr so tolle Forscher seid, warum erforscht ihr nicht mal euer eigenes Präsentationsverhalten?
Genau, und das müssen wir üben. Das ist Teil meines Arbeitsauftrages. Dass ich den jungen Menschen bei mir im Labor auch beibringe und helfe, genau diese Fähigkeit zu entwickeln. Wenn einer von uns Doktorand dann Postdoktorand einen ganz wichtigen Vortrag hält, an irgendeiner Stelle, wo es wirklich um die Wurst geht, dann hält diese Person diesen Vortrag vor dem ganzen Labor und dann wird 1 Stunde lang über jede Folie diskutiert. Dieses Bild, das ist nicht so besonders gut, ich habe gesehen, du hast ein viel stärkeres, ein viel überzeugenderes, du bringst jetzt das da. Es ist viel zu früh, das verwirrt die Leute. Du hast das ganz toll erklärt, aber die Hauptnachricht ist untergegangen. Du solltest das jetzt schon ankündigen, dass das jetzt dann und dann kommt. Und das ist wirklich sehr anstrengend, und ich mache das genauso, es ist ganz wichtig. Ich kann von meinen Leuten nicht verlangen, dass sie sich 1 Stunde lang Kritik ihres Vortrags anhören müssen, wenn ich das nicht genauso selber mache. Vor ganz wichtigen Vorträgen, mache ich das ganz genauso. Ich bitte meine Leute dazu, dass sie meinen Vortrag kritisieren. Und die tun das mit der gleichen Lust und mit der gleichen Lust, im Detail herum zu pokern, wie sie es bei ihren Peers tun. Und deshalb glaube ich, dass meine Leute im Schnitt gute Präsentationen machen, weil sie das pben und das macht auch ihren Erfolg aus. Und das ist Teil meines Jobs.
Sicherlich auch hilfreich an der Stelle auch wirklich diese Hierarchien verschwinden zu lassen.
Total wichtig. Es ist wie in einer Familie. Ich kann von meinen Kindern nicht verlangen, dass sie ehrliche Menschen werden, wenn ich selber dauernd Lüge. Die kriegen das doch mit. Ich kann mich nicht respektlos meinen Kindern gegenüber verhalten, und von ihnen Respekt einfordern, das funktioniert einfach nicht. Das funktioniert selbst in der Familie nicht, wie soll es im Job funktionieren.
Was sind denn so, wenn man mal kurz bei dem Repräsentationsthema zu bleiben, ich finde das ganz interessant. Was sind denn so die klassischen Fehler, die sich hier herausbilden?
Millionen. Ich glaube es gibt so viele Millionen klassische Fehler, dass es besser ist, auf das was man beachten sollte, zurückzugehen. Zuerst einmal muss frei gesprochen werden und es muss ganz klar werden, was die Frage ist. Und meine goldene Regel lautet immer, ich bin ein experimentell arbeitender Wissenschaftler, deshalb ist die goldene Regel natürlich ein bisschen experimentell gedacht, man muss, bevor man etwas präsentieren will, sich alles das, was man präsentieren möchte, in drei Sätzen sagen können. Die erste Frage, der erste Satz ist, was will ich sagen, was will ich erforschen. Was ist die Frage. Man darf nicht mehr als einen Satz sagen dazu. Die zweite ist, wie erforsche ich das. Auch maximal ein Satz. Und die dritte ist, was ist herausgekommen. Auch maximal ein Satz. Und erst dann, und dann wenn ich in der Lage bin, drei Sätze zu produzieren, kann ich mich überhaupt erst an meinen Vortrag dran setzen. Weil dann habe ich das für mich so runter gekocht, dass ich all die Ornamente weggeschnitten habe, die der Zuhörer sowieso nicht mehr erinnern kann. Und dann mache ich mich an diesen Holzschnitt dran und versuche, das in meiner Präsentation umzusetzen. Und man muss dann natürlich hier und da Ornamente einbauen, weil es ist ganz wichtig, jeder weiß, der Teufel steckt im Detail, manche Ornamente sagen, welche Fehler man gemacht haben könnte, muss klarstellen, dass man die nicht gemacht hat usw. und so fort. Aber das Ganze muss möglichst schlicht sein. Die Folien dürfen nicht überladen sein. Am Ende muss man noch einmal kurz wiederholen, was man gesagt hat. Und man muss immer damit rechnen, dass 5 % maximal erinnert wird. Und diese 5 % dürfen nicht die schlecht sitzende Krawatte sein. Sondern die 5 % muss das sein, was ich bestimme. Ich muss um diese 5 % kämpfen. Und wenn mir das nicht gelingt, dann bleibt wirklich nur die schlecht sitzende Krawatte übrig oder dieser grauenhafte Vortrag oder dieser Mensch, den ich nie wieder sehen möchte. Es gibt Leute, die verlassen einen Seminarraum, haben einen Vortrag gehalten, man hat sie in dem Moment vergessen, man kann sich nicht mehr an die Person erinnern. Und das darf nicht passieren. Deshalb muss man die 5 % vorher ganz klar für sich definieren und die müssen hängen bleiben. Und dafür muss man sorgen.
Mit anderen Worten, präsentieren ist richtig auch ein Teil der täglichen Arbeit mit Studenten, Postdocs mit allen eigentlich.
Absolut, auch mit Studenten. Absolut.
Finde ich gut. Finde ich gut. Ich finde auch, das sollte eigentlich schon auch in der Schule mehr Gewicht bekommen. Also das ist für meinen Geschmack noch nicht ausreichend hat. Kommen wir vielleicht mal mehr zu diesem Aspekt des Durchsetzens der eigenen Ideen, weil letzten Endes forschen kann man vor allem dann, wenn man auch die entsprechenden Mittel hat oder Aufträge überhaupt erst mal oder Erlaubnisse sich bestimmter Themen anzunehmen, um dann entsprechend die Mittel auch anzuwerben. Dazu muss man sich ja auch innerhalb seines Umfeldes durchsetzen, bzw. teilweise eben auch dann schon extern nach weiteren Geldgebern suchen. An der Stelle denke ich kommt noch mal über die gute Präsentation selbst hinaus auch noch mal ganz andere Anforderungen mit rein.
Genau, das ist so. Die sind überlappend die Anforderungen, aber sie sind natürlich schon etwas anders. In der Regel fängt man ja immer klein an. Nehmen wir mal das Möbelhaus Ikea, dass war ja nicht mit einem Schlag da, sondern irgendwann hat der Erfinder mal seinen ersten Tisch verkauft oder was auch immer er verkauft hat und das wurde dann immer größer. D.h. man fängt klein an, man hat dann ein sehr überschaubares kleines Projekt, und man möchte Geld für einen Doktoranden haben für zwei Jahre, das ist so ein bisschen der unterste Tarif. Und da muss man schon vorlegen, dass man das auch kann. Dass die Idee vernünftig ist, und dass man auch einen guten Plan hat, was mit diesem Doktoranden passieren soll. D.h. das ist sozusagen das erste kleine Projekt, das muss sitzen, das muss gut sein. Das gehe ich mit meinen Leuten im Labor dann natürlich genauso durch, hast du, bist du überzeugend, wenn jemand kritisch fragt, kannst du das überhaupt? Verstehst du was davon? Ist die Frage wichtig genug? Warum ist die Frage wichtig? Was haben wir davon, wenn wir das erforscht haben? Ist das Geld gut angelegt? Bist du in der Lage, diese ganzen Fragen adäquat zu beantworten? So fängt es an. Und wenn man das dann hat, und wenn das dann immer größer wird, kommen dann immer größere Projekte dazu, die Grundmechanismen bleiben aber natürlich immer die gleichen. Ich bin ein halbwegs bekannter Wissenschaftler jetzt in Deutschland, aber in jedem Antrag, den ich schreibe, muss ich immer noch begründen und das ist auch gut so, dass ich etwas von dem Thema verstehe, dass das Thema wichtig ist, dass ich in der Lage bin, dieses Projekt künftig zu Ende zu bringen, und ich muss auch sagen, schaut her ich war euch bisher soundso viele Millionen Euro wert, aber es ist etwas herausgekommen. Das ist meine Erfolgsliste. Und das muss ich machen, das muss ich jedes Mal machen und das ist gut so. Denn das Geld ist ja vom Steuerzahler, der sagte ja nicht, ich bin Professor soundso viel, ich kriege die Millionen, egal was ich gerade sagen. Ich muss es jedes Mal begründen. Und das finde ich ist absolut kompatibel mit meinem Verständnis von Demokratie.
Da kommen wir so langsam auch ein bisschen in das Verhältnis zur Öffentlichkeit hinein. Bevor wir das noch mal genauer anschauen, das Wort Dokumentation ist gerade bei mir hängen geblieben. Die eigene Arbeit zu dokumentieren, über ein Paper vielleicht hinaus, gerade um es auch anderen Leuten und Gruppen, Entscheidern zu kommunizieren, die jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt die Sprache von wissenschaftlichen Papern als solche verstehen. Also für die die Existenz eines Papers vielleicht auch wichtig ist, und was weiß ich, vielleicht Zitat und Erwähnungen auch nachvollziehen können. Wie dokumentieren sie denn ihre Arbeit, oder welchen Anspruch an Dokumentation haben Sie denn? Was muss denn über sozusagen das eigentliche wissenschaftliche Ergebnis eines Papers hinaus getan werden?
Ich will mal vom Kleinen anfangen bis zum etwas größeren. Also wenn Sie auf die Webseite meines Labors gehen, dann finden Sie auf dieser ersten Seite immer eine kurze Kolumne zu jeder Publikation, diese Kolumne ist allgemeinverständlich und sie ist so ein bisschen lesenswert gemacht und fasst das Ganze irgendwie einfach in einer sehr einfachen, aber klar verständlichen Art und Weise zusammen. Was beschreibt diese Publikation? Wer war daran beteiligt? Warum ist das wichtig? Was ist raus gekommen? Und das kann jeder lesen. Ich glaube das ist ein kleines Stück der Dokumentation nach außen. D.h., schaut her, diese Publikation, du kannst sie auch gerne herunterladen, du kannst sie auch lesen, aber da steht ganz viel fremdartiges Zeug drin, es reicht, wenn du dieses allgemeinverständliche Abstract liest. Das ist ein kleiner Teil dieser Art von Dokumentation. Das zweite ist, das setzt sich in meiner Universitätsarbeit fort, ich muss es auch den Studenten gegenüber erzählen können. Denn die Studenten sind natürlich viel mehr Paper lesen gewöhnt, aber auch sie müssen eine verständliche Sprache bekommen und ganz wichtig ist das, was ich jetzt in diesem Augenblick in diesem Studio mache. D.h. also ich erzähle über Forschung in einer Art und Weise, die nicht mit Fremdwörtern gespickt ist und die einfach dem interessierten Menschen von dessen Steuergeldern ich lebe, klarmacht, warum ich das tue, was ich tue. Und das ist auch ein wichtiger Teil meiner Arbeit.
Ist es denn schon, wenn man jetzt, ich will noch mal ein bisschen bei dem eigentlichen Projektanbahnungen noch bleiben, also wenn man jetzt eine neue Forschungsfront aufmachen möchte, man hat jetzt bei der bisherigen Arbeit einfach so ein paar neue Felder aufgemacht und festgestellt, ah, da gibt es ja auch interessante Forschung in dem Bereich, und so, da müsste man mal vielleicht mal rein stoßen, dass sieht irgendwie ganz interessant aus, wie setzen wir das denn jetzt auf? Muss man dazu im Prinzip eine eigene Kommunikationskampagne entwerfen? Mit wem muss man reden?
Also eine Kampagne, das ist natürlich ein schweres Wort, ich kann mich jetzt nicht erinnern, dass es, also ich zumindest habe jetzt nie wirklich Kampagnen gemacht, ich kann mich jetzt auch nicht an entsprechende Kampagnen erinnern. Manchmal gibt es große wissenschaftliche Schlachten. Die wirklich jahrelang ausgefochten werden, auf der ganzen Welt. Und da bilden sich dann häufig irgendwie zwei oder drei Gruppen, die das eine oder das andere für das richtige halten, das ist total spannend. Das ist dann Wissenschaft pur, da setzen sich dann die Leute ins Labor und tüfteln über die kritischen Experimente, um zu zeigen, dass die eigene Idee die richtige ist und die andere die falsche. Das sind jetzt nicht unbedingt Kampagnen nach außen, sondern das sind Kampagnen innerhalb des Feldes. Man hat eine tolle neue Idee, und diese neue Idee, die soll alles revolutionieren. Kampagnen, um wirklich sozusagen die Menschen außerhalb der Wissenschaft, des eigentlichen Wissenschaftsbetriebs zu erreichen, zumindest in meinem Feld gibt es das ja doch, wenn ich jetzt genau überlege, diese Debatte um den freien Willen, die erinnert ein kleines bisschen daran, dass war ja wirklich so eine Art, wir Neurowissenschaftler sagen, es gibt keinen freien Willen und das hat Implikationen zum Beispiel für das juristische System. Das kam aus dem Inneren der Wissenschaft, war innerhalb der Wissenschaft aber eigentlich kein besonders großes Thema, weil die meisten dieses als für eine Aussage hielten, die sie eigentlich so nicht treffen wollen würden, in dem extremen Maße. Und irgendwie gelang das plötzlich in die Medien, das war ein riesen Aufhänger. Und dann wurde viel darüber diskutiert und es wird immer noch darüber diskutiert. Es ist vollkommen verrückt, wenn man als Neurowissenschaftler irgendwo unterwegs ist, Party, man hat Bier, man denkt, das Leben ist schön, und plötzlich kommt irgendeiner und sagt, sag mal gibt es den freien Willen? Da weiß man, ach scheiße der hat Feuilleton von dem und dem gelesen. Das erinnerte so ein bisschen an diese Kampagnengeschichte. Ganz wichtige Kampagne im Moment, die von Wissenschaftlern in Kombination mit Politikern getrieben wird ist natürlich die Erderwärmung. Da sehen wir, dass Wissenschaftler sich zu großen Interessen- und Wissenschaftsinteressengruppen zusammen tun können. Jetzt wo ich darüber nachdenke, fällt mir ein, es gab so ein bisschen so was ähnliches, in dem, was ich mitgemacht habe, wir haben ein vollkommen neues Bild der Evolution des Gehirns festgemacht an dem Vergleich, Vogelgehirn, Säugetiergehirn gehabt. Da haben wir jahrelang eine kritische Konferenz vorbereitet. Und das Ende haben wir dann wirklich sehr medienwirksam vorangetragen, um klarzumachen, dass wir eine ganz neue Idee haben, eine ganz neue Konzeption.
Das Ende wovon?
Das Ende einer 100 Jahre alten Idee, wie die Evolution des Wirbeltiergehirns, wir sind ja Wirbeltiere, da gehören auch Fische, Amphibien, Reptilienvögel und Säugetiere dazu, und wir hatten eine ganz neue Idee, zumindest in einem ganz wichtigen Segment, wie diese Evolution eigentlich vonstatten gegangen ist. Und diese grundsätzliche Idee hat Implikationen auf die ganze Art und Weise, wie wir Kognition im Säugetiergehirn sehen und Kognition Vogelgehirn sehen. Diese Theorie, die seit 100 Jahren Bestand hatte, pflanzt sich fort in allen möglichen Subideen, die in allen möglichen Textbüchern rumgeistern und bis in die Nomenklatur von Hirnstrukturen. Und wir haben behauptet, die grundsätzliche Annahme dieser Idee ist falsch. Und daraus folgt sehr viel. Und als wir am Ende unseres Workshops an der Duke Universität unausgeschlafen, unrasiert, fertig mit den Nerven, aber wir 27 Leute, die wir dann da wirklich waren und haben gesagt, jetzt ist es das, eine neue Ära beginnt, geht alles unter, was wir jetzt erarbeitet haben, wie fassen wir das an? Und wir haben uns wirklich zusammengesetzt und ja in dem Sinne eine Kampagne entworfen. Diese Kampagne muss immer in ihrem Kern gute Wissenschaft haben. Da müssen die entsprechenden Publikationen kommen. Aber da gehört auch die Kommunikation mit den Medien dazu, aber dann auch die Kommunikation innerhalb des Feldes. Weil das schlimmste was passieren kann, ist, dass man komplett ignoriert wird. Und das ist das, was auch passieren kann. Da macht sich eine Gruppe von Wissenschaftlern auf, die Welt neu zu erfinden und keiner hört zu. Und irgendwann ist es vergessen. Und das war unsere größte Angst. Keiner hört zu. Und wir waren überwältigt, wie viel die Leute zugehört haben. Und es war eine Revolution, die geklappt hat. Aber wir haben versucht, ähnliche Revolutionen nachzuvollziehen, und wir haben elf herausbekommen, in dem Feld, um das es ging, und nur drei hatten geklappt. Die anderen sind sang und klanglos untergegangen.
Was war denn dann der Schlüssel zum Erfolg, jetzt bei dieser Kampagne, wenn man das mal so nennt?
Der Schlüssel zum Erfolg war letztendlich, dass jeder der sich damit beschäftigte zu der Schlussfolgerung kam, das war überfällig, also das alte Gebäude war morsch, es musste nur einer mal dagegen treten.
Zweifelstimmung nennt man das in der Politik.
Exakt, genau. Das zweite ist, in dieser Konferenz waren alle Leute da, oder fast alle Leute da, die Rang und Namen hatten. Mit einigen wenigen Ausnahmen, die dann auch sehr vehement dagegen opponiert haben. Aber sozusagen die erdrückende Mehrheit der Meinungsbilden Menschen waren da.
Aber auch die andere Meinung war wichtig, weil wenn die nicht zur Diskussion gestanden hätte, hätten die dann aus der Ferne gesagt, ja ihr damit euer Lagerdenken und so.
Exakt. Und dann haben wir natürlich sehr gezielt geguckt…
Moment, war das dann auch so eine Einladungspolitik, an der Stelle, dass man darauf hingewirkt hat, dass bestimmte Leute auch an dieser Konferenz teilnehmen?
Absolut, jeder war eingeladen. Wir haben drei Jahre diese Konferenz vorbereitet. Das war ein Workshop. Wir haben drei Jahre vorbereitet. Weil das blöde ist, man kann nicht über die Wahrheit abstimmen. Wir können nicht hingehen und da am Tempelhofer Feld einfach hinein rufen, ist die Welt rund oder ist sie eine Scheibe? Oder irgendetwas anderes. Und die Leute sagen irgendwie zu 78 %, sie ist eine Scheibe, dann ist es trotzdem falsch. Man kann also nicht über die Wahrheit abstimmen. Aber wir müssen irgendwie zu einem Konsens kommen. Und wie sieht der Konsens aus. Und da haben wir drei Jahre dran gebrütet, bis wir das hatten. Wir waren uns im klaren darüber, dass es immer sein kann, dass es Minderheitenvoten gibt. Die dürfen aber das Ganze nicht blockieren. Wir haben also eine Schwelle von 80 % definiert. Wir müssen mindestens 80 % erreichen, um etwas als Gruppe zu beschließen, aber dann das Minderheitenvotum immer mit kommunizieren. Dann teilen wir dieses Problemfeld auf in kleinere Untergruppen und jede Untergruppe bekommt eine kleine Untergruppe. Und diese Untergruppe kommuniziert über ihre Sprecher mit den anderen Gruppen. Wir haben sozusagen ein feingefädelten Stundenplan gehabt, in denen in kleinen Gruppen, wo die Ultraspezialisten sitzen, dann über zu Lösungen kommen, die wird dann über den Spokesman kommuniziert mit den anderen und derweil waren wahrscheinlich 70-80 Wissenschaftler auf der ganzen Welt quasi zugeschaltet und wurden dann immer wieder gefragt, könntest du leben da und damit? Oder sähest du damit ein ganz großes Problem? Wir hatten sogar zum Beispiel einen Kollegen aus Deutschland, der konnte wahnsinnig gut Latein, der half uns mit der neuen Nomenklatur, weil man macht sich mit nichts noch lächerlicher, als mit einem Grammatikfehler im Lateinischen, wenn man eine neue Nomenklatur finden. Also selbst daran mussten wir dann denken.
Ja. Was für neue Namen waren denn hier erforderlich? Sie sagten ja, die Nomenklatur hat schon diese Falschannahmen getragen.
Ja, eine Nomenklatur ist ja nicht einfach nur, das ist, was weiß ich, die Kiste rechts oben, sondern es ist sozusagen die alte Kiste rechts oben, die neben der neuen steht. Und da ist alt und neu dabei. Und was ist alt, und was ist neu? Dazu muss es ja irgendwo einen Nullpunkt geben. Dieser Nullpunkt bedeutet, man hat eine Theorie, was der Nullpunkt ist. Wenn aber diese Theorie falsch ist, kann diese alte Kiste vielleicht genauso alt sein wie die neue, aber der Name ist dann falsch. D.h. all diese Namen beinhalteten die alten Namen. Beinhalteten eine 100 Jahre alte Theorie, die grundsätzlich falsch war. Und wir mussten dann neue Namen erfinden, um diese neue Theorie auch zu substanziieren, sie musste ja benennbar sein im alltäglichen Leben. Und dabei treten dann so ganz komische, geradezu lächerliche Probleme auf, ich möchte Ihnen ein Beispiel geben, das ist das einzige Fremdwort, nein zwei Fremdworte, die muss ich jetzt verwenden. Es gibt sozusagen mein Lieblingsareal im Gehirn, das nennt sich Neostriatum kaudolaterale. D.h. also das ist das neue gestreifte Gebiet und das sitzt hinten an der Seite. Das Wort Striatum beinhaltet, dass es nicht Kortex ist. Wir wissen aber, dass es zwar nicht Kortex ist, aber kortexähnlich ist. Nach unserer neuen Meinung. Und definitiv ist das Wort Striatum falsch. Wir müssen es ersetzen durch etwas anderes. Wir müssen es also durch das Wort Pallium ersetzen, das ist das richtige. Und das Wort Neo beinhaltet, dass es das neue Striatum ist. Striatum ist schon gestrichen, ist durch Pallium ersetzt. Aber es ist nicht neu, wir können also nicht Neo sagen. Denn das wäre wieder eine sprachliche Konnotation, die falsch wäre. Jetzt kam ich zum Beispiel und sagte, wir reden ja gar nicht mit als Neostriatum kaudolateralem im umgangssprachlichen, wir sagen NCL, die Abkürzung. Und wir haben Jahrzehnte Literatur, wo NCL auftauchen. Wenn wir jetzt einen vollkommen neuen Namen uns ausdenken, der heißt AVL, dann versteht einfach, dann verstehen die neuen Schüler die alte Literatur nicht mehr. Wir müssen also bei NCL bleiben. CL ist kein Problem, weil das Ding ist immer noch hinten an der Seite. Also kaudolaterale behalten wir dabei, aber wir müssen uns ein neues Wort mit N ausdenken und es muss Lateinisch sein. Und es muss mit Pallium enden. Und irgendwann spät in der Nacht, wo wir schon fertig waren mit den Nerven, kam dann irgend einer auf die Idee und nannte es Nidopallium kaudolaterale. Nido von lateinisch Nest, das hat keinerlei theoretischen Bezug, aber das hat so ein bisschen eine nestartige Struktur, dieses Gebiet, weil von dem ausgehend gehen viele andere Areale aus, das kann auch in 100 Jahren nicht falsch sein. Also haben wir gedacht, o. k., fängt mit N an ist lateinisch, kann nicht wirklich falsch sein und jetzt heißt das Ding Nidopallium kaudolaterale und abgekürzt NCL. So müssen Sie sich das vorstellen. Das sind sozusagen die Dinge, die einen dann um 3:00 Uhr morgens beschäftigen.
Der Kampf um die Details. Mir fällt da gleich diese Debatte, die ja in der Astronomie geführt wurde, um die Planeten und sozusagen um die Entweihung des Pluto, vielleicht mittlerweile fast schon auch eine der populärsten Geschichten aus diesem Bereich. Aber das trifft es ja auch. Man hat halt irgendwie festgestellt, naja so richtig war das halt nicht, wie gehen wir jetzt den Kompromiss mit Pluto ein, damit der nicht beleidigt ist. Und die damit zusammenhängenden Wissenschaftler. Klingt eigentlich nach einer ganz unterhaltsamen Sitzung, die das gewesen sein muss.
Total. Das war vielleicht der spannendste Workshop meines Lebens.
Wenn man jetzt, also das ist eine interessante Geschichte, weil jetzt ja wirklich sozusagen auch nicht nur der Aspekt drin ist, wie komme ich überhaupt zu meinem Projekt, sondern wie verschaffe ich dem letzten Endes auch Geltung, weil es muss unglaublich frustrierend sein, wenn man irgendwie jahrelang an irgendetwas gearbeitet hat und dann nimmt es irgendwie überhaupt gar keiner zur Kenntnis.
Genau, das passiert sehr häufig.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wie frustrierend muss das sein.
Das ist sehr frustrierend, vor allen Dingen weil man dann wirklich auch an der Richtigkeit dessen glaubt, und wahrscheinlich irgendwann dann auch anfängt, ins Zweifeln zu kommen. Es gibt immer diese traurigen Geschichten. Ich erzähle eine von den vielen vielen traurigen Geschichten. Ein Wissenschaftler hier in Deutschland, der hat jahrelang für eine bestimmte Sache gestritten, aber irgendwie immer ein bisschen nicht besonders glücklich und war auch vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig glaubwürdig, aber er hat wirklich sehr daran geglaubt. Das war sein geistiges Baby. Und er hatte eine technische Mitarbeiterin, die hat in einem unendlichen Fleiß hunderttausende von Hirnschnitten für ihn angefertigt, die dann dazu dienen sollten, diese seine zentrale Theorie zu untermauern. Und es hat nicht geklappt. Und irgendwann ging er in Rente und hat alle Schnitte vernichtet. Obwohl diese Schnitte erst mal eigentlich ja streng genommen ihm nicht gehörten, sondern dem Institut. Zweitens diese Schnitte von einer Beschaffenheit sind, dass man die sich noch in 100 Jahren hätte angucken können. Eine Quelle des Wissens für viele viele Jahrzehnte. Vielleicht nie genutzt, aber eigentlich prinzipiell machbar. Er hat sie vernichtet, weil er einfach mit einem Leben abschließen wollte, dass als tiefste Frustration geendet hat. Er hat für etwas gekämpft und gestritten, mit all seiner Intelligenz dafür gearbeitet, kein Mensch hat ihm geglaubt und so sollten auch die Zeugnisse seiner Niederlage vernichtet werden. Das passiert. Ich glaube, das passiert in allen Wissenschaften. Da kenne ich jede Menge Beispiele. Und es gibt auch zum Beispiel aber auch das umgekehrte. Es gibt hochgradig produktive Wissenschaftler, die Spuren ihrer Produktivität in vergänglichen, jetzt in meinem Bereich, Hirnschnitten hinterlassen. Davon aber nur einen kleinen Teil berichten können, aber die anderen sind auch wichtig. Und seit einigen Jahren geht unter uns die Angst um, dass diese Kollegen in Rente gehen, drei Jahre später betritt irgendein Hausmeister ein Archiv, sagt, dass es jetzt der Raum, den ich jetzt leerräumen möchte. Was sind eigentlich diese ganzen Kisten, na gut ist ja egal, kommt jetzt alles in den Sperrmüll. Und damit gehen 40 Jahre Wissenschaft darnieder, und was wir jetzt eben mehr und mehr machen und wir wollen das auch in meiner Heimatuniversität in Bochum einrichten, dass wir diese ultrahochauflösenden digitalen Mikroskope haben, mit denen wir dann einfach von einer Reihe ausgesuchter Kolleginnen und Kollegen deren Lebenswerk in Mikroskopieschnitten einlesen und somit Datenbanken schaffen, die solange das digitale Leben gibt, theoretisch für unendlich lange zugänglich sind. Es gibt beides, es gibt das frustrierte Vernichten und es gibt das ungewollte vernichten. Einfach weil man noch nicht das Medium hatte, um das aufzubewahren.
Sind wir eigentlich schon wieder bei dem Bereich Dokumentation, Archivierung. Sicherlich ein gewisser Grad an Archivierung hat immer stattgefunden, aber die Digitalisierung bietet hier ja auch ganz andere Möglichkeiten. Und auch nicht nur hier jetzt, um diese Arbeit einzelner Wissenschaftler anderen Wissenschaftlern zukünftig zugänglich zu machen, sondern die „einfache“ digitale, also die Möglichkeit der Digitalisierung eines Großteils der Ergebnisse würde ja auch ein ganz anderes Forschen ermöglichen. Ich will jetzt nicht mit den super populären Begriffen ankommen, wie Croudsourcing. Aber zumindest kann man ja darauf hin arbeiten, dass überhaupt das Auffindbarmachen und das Aufgreifen von getaner Arbeit noch weiter zu erleichtern.
Absolut. Und das passiert. Dazu muss man sagen, gehört ein Menschenbild, das diametral dem entgegensteht, was die klassische Soziobiologie eigentlich über uns immer sagt. Die klassische Soziobiologie sagt ja, wir müssen Egoisten sein, sonst können wir uns gar nicht vernünftig durchsetzen. Wir müssen uns irgendwo genetisch durchsetzen und wir helfen den Leuten, von denen wir dann später irgendeinen sozusagen Return erwarten. Wir helfen auch Leuten, mit denen wir verwandt sind, auch von denen ein Return bekommen. Wir wissen aber, also die tragen unsere Gene, das ist also tit for tat, ich gebe Ihnen jetzt eine Schokolade und irgendwann bekomme ich von Ihnen Schokolade usw. und so fort. Und das ist auch wahnsinnig überzeugend alles. Und dann guckt man sich mal selber an und denkt, scheiße das stimmt ja gar nicht. So bin ich gar nicht. Ich gebe einem vollkommen mir unbekannten Menschen in einem Katastrophengebiet in Indonesien 500 € und ich sehe dieses Geld nie wieder und ich werde diese Person, die von diesem Geld irgendetwas bekommt nie wieder sehen. Weder bin ich religiös und erwarte, dass ich deshalb ins Paradies komme, noch passiert irgendetwas anderes in meinem Leben. D.h. ich habe dieses Geld einfach weggegeben, ohne dass ich im strengen Sinne irgendetwas dazu bekomme. Und denken Sie zum Beispiel gerade im Computerbereich an all das, was die Menschen einfach programmieren und dann einfach weggeben für nichts. Wikipedia ist ein solches Beispiel, Linux, viele viele andere Dinge sind solche Beispiele und Wissenschaft ist ein weiteres Beispiel. Wissenschaftler machen ganz viele Dinge, die sie einfach ins Netz stellen, ich natürlich genauso. Man stellt seine Ergebnisse ins Netz und sagt, seid bitte so freundlich, wenn ihr das benutzt, zitiert mich zumindest oder denkt abends vorm Einschlafen mal kurz an mich. Macht irgendetwas, um zumindest zu honorieren, dass ich diese geistige Arbeit jahrelang geleistet habe. Und so entstehen riesige Datenbanken in der Wissenschaft, auf die wir alle zurückgreifen. Und das ist durch das digitale Zeitalter erst ermöglicht worden und das wird viel viel mehr werden. Dieses auf 1-Click zugreifen auf gigantische Datenbanken, mit denen ich dann arbeiten kann. Mit denen ich mal eben eine Idee abchecken kann, ich gucke auf eine Gendatenbank und sage, macht das Sinn? 20 Minuten später weiß ich, o. k. brauche ich gar nicht reinzugehen, das macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Weil die genetische Konstellation ist soundso und soundso und die Idee war falsch. Und das kann ich machen. Und es kostet mich nichts. Und das ist toll und das wird immer mehr werden.
Aber die Widerstände scheinen auch da zu sein. Ich erinnere mich gerade selber an einen Fall, den ich selber erlebt habe. Ich bin an einer Uniklinik zu einem öffentlichen Vortrag gegangen, was ich schon mal ganz interessant fand, die wohl regelmäßig stattfinden, so einmal im Monat. Ich will jetzt mal nicht sagen wo, ist auch egal. So hat dann dort eine Wissenschaftlerin, die sich in einem bestimmten medizinischen Bereich gut auskennt dann mal so den Stand der Forschung zusammengefasst. Und es war so ein Hörsaal und der war rappelvoll. Das war einfach bis auf den allerletzten Platz einfach ganz normale Leute, die entweder davon betroffen waren von diesem Krankheitsbild oder auch nur glaubten, dass sie es vielleicht sein könnten, das weiß ich so im einzelnen nicht. Sehr viele Nachfragen, sehr viele interessante Diskussionen, die dann im Nachgang auch noch aufkamen. Und der Vortrag war auch an sich gut vorgetragen, erfüllte also auch so die vorhin besprochenen Anforderungen eigentlich wunderbar. Und ich dachte mir dann so am Schluss so, das war doch jetzt mal wirklich ein substantieller Beitrag, und vor allem auch eine Kommunikation in so eine ganz andere Öffentlichkeit hinein. Also auch in so eine Betroffenheit. Da wurde sozusagen das wissenschaftliche Ergebnis extrem greifbar, weil deswegen wurde es ja überhaupt auch erst gemacht. Und als dann noch so die Nachfragen waren und sie schon fast am Gehen war, habe ich sie dann noch mal auf den letzten Metern so kurz gestoppt und gemeint, eine Frage habe ich noch. Wieso? Wieso ist denn dieser Vortrag jetzt nicht im Internet? Ich meine, so viele Leute wie das hier interessiert hat, das ist jetzt auch sagen wir mal so, wie es hier zusammengefasst wurde, ein Wert, der, was weiß ich, das hätte jetzt sicherlich noch 3-4 Jahre lang noch topaktuell sein können. Sicherlich der ein oder andere Durchbruch hätte vielleicht noch mal das ein oder andere in Frage gestellt, aber da einfach so viel Grundlagenwissen gut vermittelt worden, was den Leuten echt weitergeholfen hat. Und sie schaute mich einfach nur an und meinte so, nein geistiges Eigentum. Das sollen mal andere machen. Und macht auf dem Absatz kehrt und war schon irgendwie davon. Wo so ein bisschen innerlich in mir auch etwas starb irgendwie in dem Moment. Das hat mich wirklich schockiert, aber da merkt man halt auch immer wieder, es scheint da auch irgendwie teilweise noch eine ganz andere Sicht zu geben, die sich so nicht so ganz nachvollziehen lässt.
Aber ich bin ja hier, weil ich meine Sicht erzähle. Also klar, das kann es geben. Ich selbst in diesem Extrem habe ich es selbst noch nicht erlebt, aber das gibt es mit Sicherheit. Was es gibt und was ich selber natürlich auch erlebe ist folgendes, man hat eine Präsentation, da sind was weiß ich 25 Folien, da sind alle möglichen Grafiken drin, aber auch teilweise irgendetwas, was man aus dem Internet mal runter geladen hat, um etwas bestimmtes zu zeigen. Und dann kommt mit Sicherheit, in den letzten Jahren immer mehr, kommt dann irgend ein junger Mann runter und sagt, so das würden wir jetzt gern Posten auf dem soundso Ding, und sie müssen hier nur unterschreiben, dass sie damit einverstanden sind. Im Prinzip gerne, hundertprozentig, bloß ich muss mich jetzt wochenlang auf die Suche machen, von jedem einzelnen Bild, von jeder einzelnen Grafik, sowohl von dem Autor als auch von der Zeitschrift dann die Permission zu holen, dass das dann auf dieser Seite landen kann. Und dann gibt es immer diese bösartigen Geschichten. Ich habe irgend ein Bild, was wahnsinnig gut dazu passt mal irgendwann im Internet gesehen, das habe ich mir mal runter geladen und das passt wie die Faust aufs Auge, aber ich kriege jetzt nicht mehr hin, wo das herkommt. Und da muss ich auch noch unterschreiben, das sich vollständig dafür verantwortlich bin, dass das alles mein Eigentum ist usw. und so fort. Und ich glaube das ist ein Problem, das wir haben, das ich habe ganz konkret, es gibt zwei solche Vorträge, wo jetzt immer noch traurige Briefe kommen, können wir das nicht, sollen wir das nicht, und dann sage ich immer, Leute wir können das gerne, aber ihr nehmt mir die Arbeit ab, all diese Dinge nach zu recherchieren. Denn ich weiß von diesem Bild Nummer drei und Nummer zwölf nicht mehr, wo ich die her habe. Die Bilder soundso soundso soundso und soundso, das sind die und die Publikationen usw. Da haben wir ein juristisches Problem, dass ich ohne jeden juristischen Sachverstand irgendwie inhaltlich nachvollziehen kann, aber das nimmt mir auch ein bisschen die Lust an genau diesen Sachen. Das ist aber glaube ich auf einer ganz anderen Ebene, als das was Sie gerade beschreiben. Denn geistiges Eigentum kann etwas ja gar nicht sein, sobald ich es im strengsten Sinne publiziere. Weil als Wissenschaftler bin ich ja dafür da, genau meine Ergebnisse allgemein zugänglich zu machen, erst mal innerhalb der Wissenschaftscommunity und dann jenseits dessen und dann kann ich zwar immer noch sagen, ich habe es erfunden, aber ich kann nicht sagen, kein Mensch darf mehr daran arbeiten, weil ich arbeite daran. Es gibt aber ein paar Wissenschaftler, Gott sei Dank sind sie selten, sonst wäre das kein schöner Beruf, die verhalten sich wirklich so. Also die haben wirklich den verrückten Glauben, das ist mein Gebet und da kommst du nicht rein. Passiert nicht sehr häufig, aber passiert. Selten.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch die Frage, ich meine gerade als Wissenschaftler hat man ja, also welcher Wissenschaftler arbeitet schon in einer komplett privat finanzierten Umgebung. Also das fängt ja mit der Universität, der Ausbildung, der Schule im Prinzip ja schon an, der Staat, die Gesellschaft trägt ja dazu bei, dass solche Systeme überhaupt erst einmal errichtet und dann natürlich auch erhalten, finanziert werden. Da entsteht ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht, wie ich zumindest finde, eine gewisse Verpflichtung daraus, der man an der Stelle vielleicht nachkommen würde. Diese Problematik, ich meine, ehrlich gesagt ich weiß nicht genau, wie sie es gemeint hat, das war so ihr Ruf und offensichtlich hatte sie in diesem Moment auch wenig Zeit, also das ist jetzt nicht wirklich ausdiskutiert worden, ich war von der Geschwindigkeit der Antwort ein wenig getroffen. Trotz alledem das was wir hier ansprechen, das sind ja auch Fragestellungen fair use von solchen Sachen. Ich meine, wer kennt diese Problematik nicht. Und ich meine, wer sich sicher zu sein scheint, dass irgend ein Bild als kannst du verwenden ist unter dieser Lizenz veröffentlicht worden usw., nicht beschützt einen davor, dass man dann gleich die Abmahnkeule eine Woche später auf dem Tisch hat, von irgendeinem durchgedrehten Anwaltsbüro, der halt gnadenlos dem hinterher recherchieren und ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste dann einfach „wir nehmen was wir kriegen können“ eben da hinterher ist. Das verhindert natürlich auch eine entsprechende Publikation. Wahrscheinlich sind hier einfach auch noch ein paar Änderungen im Umgang mit Wissen und mit Erkenntnissen generell erforderlich.
Ich glaube schon. Ich meine es ist halt so, es verändert sich peu à peu. Noch vor gar nicht allzu vielen Jahren waren die Fachzeitschriften gehörten ja dann immer weniger immer größeren Verlagen, die dann auch Preise diktieren konnten und das war eine ganz komische Ökonomie. Ich arbeite jahrelang, bis ich einen Ergebnissatz zusammen habe, dann reiche ich das ein bei dieser Zeitschrift. In dieser Zeitschrift sitzt dann ein Herausgeber, der wird kaum bezahlt von dieser Zeitschrift für seine Arbeit. Der sucht sich dann Gutachter heraus, die dann auch kostenlos mein Manuskript begutachten. Dann in der Regel dann ihr Wochenende damit verbringen. Ihr Gutachten dann zurückschicken. Dann wird entschieden, ob dieses Manuskript genommen wird oder nicht, oder ob es verändert werden muss. Dann wird es dann irgendwann gedruckt und in dem Moment, muss ich dann meinen eigenen Artikel von dieser Zeitschrift kaufen und ich muss bei allem und jedem, was mit diesem Ding passiert, erst einmal diese Zeitschrift fragen. Das ist eigentlich ein unmöglicher Markt. Das ist ein ökonomisches Modell, dass wenn man das einem vernünftigen Menschen erzählt, der nur noch den Kopf schütteln würde. Und mittlerweile ist es so, zuerst haben die Mathematiker damit angefangen, dass sie gesagt haben, wir publizieren nicht mehr bei Elsevier, auch wenn die gute Zeitschriften haben. Stopp, jetzt hört das auf dieser Unsinn, wir publizieren jetzt nur noch ganz woanders. Die anderen Verlage sind jetzt nicht viel besser. Elsevier hat es erwischt, weil der einfach so groß ist. Und deshalb schnell als besonders böse gilt. Aber mehr und mehr gibt es ja dann diese Zeitschriften, die ganz anders funktionieren, die frei zugänglich sind und die dann auch einen ganz anderen Markt schaffen. Nach wie vor gibt es dort glaube ich das Copyright-Problem, aber ganz sicher bin ich mir nicht. Es kann sein, dass das Copyright-Problem dort etwas anders ist, weil diese Zeitschriften finanzieren sich daraus, dass ich dann als Autor Geld bezahle, wenn ich einmal mein Manuskript dort abliefere, aber dann diese Zeitschriften frei zugänglich sind. Was großartig ist, weil es nämlich bedeutet, dass Tausende von Universitäten, quer über diesen Globus, die kein Geld für eine vernünftige Universitätsbibliothek haben, Studenten in allen möglichen Ländern, die froh sind, dass sie studieren können, aber unter schlimmsten Bedingungen, einfach nur das Internet brauchen. Und sie haben Zugang zu den neuesten wissenschaftlichen Ergebnissen. Das ist eine tolle Geschichte und vielleicht ändert sich damit auch ein bisschen von dieser juristischen Geschichte da, über die wir sprechen.
Also wir sprechen jetzt hier im Prinzip über die Idee von Open Access, dem publizieren im Netz, mit entsprechenden Plattformen. Wie sehen Sie so den Stand derzeit? Also wie viel Verbreitung, wie viel Skepsis wird dem noch entgegengebracht?
Am Anfang gab es natürlich eine gewisse Skepsis. Es gab beides, es gab die Enthusiasten, die sagen, das ist die Zukunft und es gab die Skeptiker. Und mittlerweile ist das ein ganz normaler Bereich des Publizierens, der genauso benutzt wird, wie die klassischeren. Ich beobachte das mehr und mehr Open Access sich breitmacht. Und ich beobachte, wie nervös natürlich die Zeitschriften werden. Und dass sich das ein bisschen natürlich auf die Geldpolitik auswirkt dieser Zeitschriften. Also eigentlich eine vernünftige Sache. Was ich nicht beobachte ist, dass jetzt ganz plötzlich die Verlage kaputtgehen. Es ist nicht so, dass es jetzt mit einem Schlag eine Wende gibt und alles ist nur noch Open Access. Vielleicht vollzieht sich das ein bisschen langsamer. Es vollzieht sich, vielleicht gibt es die dann nicht mehr, aber es vollzieht sich langsamer. Wer weiß.
Vielleicht muss sich dort einfach ein anderes Modell herausbilden, weil letzten Endes ist ja so die eigentliche Dienstleistung ist ja gar nicht so sehr das Drucken einer Zeitschrift oder das Verbreiten davon, weil das kann das Internet letzten Endes ja sehr sehr viel besser. Es ist ja quasi eine Glaubwürdigkeit, die einem Paper gegeben wird, dadurch dass es angenommen wurde und dieser Review ist ja ohnehin, wie soll ich sagen, nach wie vor ein wünschenswerter Vorgang, den man ja genauso auch auf Open Access in irgendeiner Form anwenden könnte. Es ist halt schon einmal publiziert, es gibt dann eben auch Reviewer, die vielleicht eben dafür auch bezahlt werden, dazu sagen, o. k. wir sind eine akzeptierte Instanz, die quasi einen Teil der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft ist, die sich explizit nur um diesen Publikationsaspekt kümmert.
Ich bin vollkommen Ihrer Meinung. Der eigentliche Wert einer Publikation ist nicht so sehr der Ort an dem erscheint, ob im Internet oder in einer Zeitschrift, die man in der Regel ja dann auch im Internet liest, kein Mensch geht mehr in Bibliotheken und dreht Blätter um. Sondern es ist der Begutachtungsprozess. D.h. anonyme Gutachter, die sich das Ding angeguckt haben, die daran rumgemäkelt haben und die dann im Grunde letztendlich irgendwann einen Stempel aufgedrückt haben, o. k., damit kannst du an die Öffentlichkeit. Das ist zumindest nicht falsch. Nicht sozusagen in einem primären Sinne falsch, sondern so kann man es machen. Es ist sauber gemacht. Ich bin nicht mit deiner Interpretation einverstanden, aber im Prinzip könnte man es so interpretieren. Wenn man die Welt so sieht, wie du sie siehst. Das ist der eigentliche Gütestempel. Und der ist bei Open Access natürlich ganz genauso gegeben. Ob man Gutachter bezahlen muss oder nicht, das ist eine schwierige Frage. Eine niemals endende Frage. Ich selbst bin natürlich ständig Gutachter, wie viele andere Wissenschaftler auch und wenn ich so meinem Nachbarn sage, hör mal, ich kann heute nicht auf das Grillfest kommen, ich habe noch drei Gutachten zu schreiben und ich muss die morgen abliefern. Dann denkt er, der sieht die Dollarzeichen bei sich im Auge, weil er denkt, ich verdiene damit ganz groß Geld. Dass ich hier für natürlich null Cent immer begutachte und zwar zeitlebens, das ist einem normalen Menschen kaum klarzumachen. Aber das ist in diesem System eigentlich inhärent drin. Und es ist vielleicht auch gut so, weil wenn wir anfangen, dafür zu bezahlen, müsste man sich fragen, müsste ich nicht adäquat bezahlt werden. Aber wenn ich adäquat bezahlt werden möchte, als ob ich etwas für ein Industrieunternehmen mache, dann sind das natürlich Preise, die dann blitzschnell keiner mehr bezahlen kann. Und dann bleiben, was weiß ich, nur noch 20 Länder übrig, die publizieren können. Und alle anderen müssen ihren Wissenschaftlern sagen, nein, das geht leider nicht. Du kannst nur lesen, aber schreiben darfst du nicht.
Aber es gibt durchaus auch, aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, aber auf europäischer Ebene, wenn es da um EU Projekte geht etc., da gibt es ja sehr wohl auch…
EU bezahlt für Begutachtungen von Forschungsprojekten. Das ist jetzt aber dann in der Regel nicht so, dass man dann... Das ist also mehr in der Regel, also ich würde es mehr als symbolisch sehen. Das ist nicht wirklich, so das man da echt Geld mit verdient. In der Regel ist es so, ganz früher in den ganz spartanischen Zeiten, wenn ich für die Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft dann nach Bonn musste, war die Bezahlung ein Café und wenn man Glück hatte ein Keks. Aber es gab in der Regel weniger Kekse als Gutachter, insofern war das dann schwierig. Dann kam die Zeit, in der es die berühmte DFG Cremesuppe gab und mittlerweile gibt es sogar belegte Brötchen. Das Leben wird immer besser.
Ich sehe schon. Saus und Braus. Wir sollten noch mal weitere Aspekte der Kommunikation der eigenen Wissenschaft aufrufen. Was wir ein bisschen bisher raus gelassen haben, ist dieser etwas schwierige Aspekt der Finanzierung. Schwierig insofern, als dass es natürlich immer schwierig ist, Gelder zu bekommen. Es ja aber auch in zunehmendem Maße den Druck gibt, der Drittmittelorganisationen, man also quasi gezwungen ist, außerhalb des normalen Betriebs sich nach Geldquellen umzuschauen. Und da kommt dann natürlich auch immer diese Quantität und Qualität rein. An der Stelle ist natürlich sehr wohl eine Quantität auch eine Bewertung der eigenen Arbeit, weil umso mehr man solche Finanzierungsrunden und natürlich auch umso mehr Geld man dort eingetrieben hat, umso positiver wirkt sich das natürlich auch auf die eigene wissenschaftliche Arbeit bzw. das Standing innerhalb der Organisation aus. Das kann man jetzt irgendwie kritisieren oder nicht, darauf wollte ich jetzt gar nicht so sehr hinaus, können wir natürlich auch noch mal besprechen. Ich wollte nur einfach fragen, wie sollte man sich als Wissenschaftler gegenüber diesen potentiellen Partnern, Geldgebern, das müssen jetzt nicht nur Unternehmen sein, ich weiß auch gar nicht, was es in der Regel ist, oder eben auch Stiftungen aufstellen? Wie sollte man da eine Herangehensweise machen, welche Bedeutung spielt dann auch hier die Eigenkommunikation?
In diesem Bereich ist sie natürlich besonders wichtig. Zumindest in allen experimentell arbeitenden Wissenschaften ist glaube ich Drittmittelförderung wahnsinnig wichtig, weil es gibt, Deutschland ist ein ganz guter Standort für, sagen wir mal, Kleinkleinforschung an der Universität. Weil die deutschen Universitäten geben immer eine gewisse Infrastruktur, selbst für experimentell arbeitende Wissenschaftler, man kann sich darüber beklagen, man hat irgendwie nur dieses oder jenes, aber im Großen und Ganzen geht es uns in Deutschland in der Hinsicht ganz gut. Sozusagen für das kleine alltägliche sind eigentlich die Universitäten ganz gut ausgestattet und wenn es mehr sein soll, wenn man mehr Leute haben möchte, wenn irgendwie teurere Geräte oder sonst was angeschafft werden müssen, geht es gar nicht ohne Drittmittel, das können die Universitäten gar nicht schultern. Da ist Deutschland eigentlich auch ganz gut aufgestellt, was die Drittmittelförderung angeht. Wir haben mit der Deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft ein fantastisches Förderinstrument, das ziemlich politikfern und nur qualitätsorientiert Wissenschaft fördert. Es gibt natürlich dann noch die anwendungsnäheren und politiknäheren BMBF usw., es gibt ganz viele Stiftungen, der Stifterverband wurde ja mehrfach erwähnt, aber viele andere Stiftungen auch, insofern sind wir in Deutschland eigentlich da ganz gut dran. Ich würde mal sagen, wenn man aktiv ist und wenn man vernünftige Forschung macht, ist man in Deutschland, was Drittmittel angeht, kann man nicht wirklich klagen. Worüber man in Deutschland allerhöchstens Klang kann, innerhalb der eigentlich recht positiven Rahmenbedingungen, ist, dass natürlich die Infrastruktur der Universität, dadurch, dass die der Universitäten, dass die deutschen Wissenschaftler immer Drittmittel stärker wurden, die Infrastruktur der Universitäten zurückgefahren wurde. D.h. die Universitäten zerfallen, und werden immer, da kommen immer mehr Studenten rein, und wenn man nun wirklich gar keine Drittmittel hat, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann wird das Leben an den deutschen Universitäten immer schwieriger, weil man eben auf diese zerfallende Infrastruktur angewiesen ist. Wenn man aber drittmittelfähig ist, dann ist Deutschland eigentlich ein sehr gutes Land. Weil es eine wirklich sehr politikferne, relativ großzügige und trotzdem sehr qualitätsorientierte Drittmittelförderung hat. Die ich glaube einer großen Wissenschaftsnation gut zu Gesicht steht.
Was sind denn so die primären Drittmittelquellen?
Das kann ich jetzt für mich zum Beispiel sagen, das ist für mich dann immer die Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft. Weil sie eben dieses Prinzip hat, komm mit egal was dich gerade interessierst, interessierst du dich für Flechten, wunderbar. Interessierst du dich für die Bedeutung des Wortes niemals im chinesisch des fünften Jahrhunderts, großartig. Komm mit allem was du hast zu mir. Solange es gute Qualität hat, wirst du gefordert werden. Und das ist einzigartig. Das ist wirklich selten. Gleichzeitig ist die Förderquote…
Also selten im weltweiten.
Ja.
Das blöde in den USA zum Beispiel, wenn sie Förderquoten haben von 8 % oder 9 % oder 7 %, und Sie müssen damit teilweise Ihr eigenes Gehalt finanzieren, dann haben Sie ganz andere Strategien. Dann arbeiten Sie nicht mehr daran, was Sie gerade interessiert und versuchen, darin immer besser zu werden, sondern Sie versuchen die ganze Zeit, zu erschnüffeln, woher weht der Wind, um Ihre Siegeschancen zu maximieren. D.h. Sie forschen dann an dem, was gerade im Moment ziemlich gut klingt. Weil Sie einfach so verzweifelt sind, ob der niedrigen Förderquote. Und das ist ein ganz ungesunder Zustand. Und die USA machen mir große Sorgen. Das ist die größte Wissenschaftsnation und wir sind eine Welt von Wissenschaftlern und wenn unser größter Bruder langsam in die Knie geht, dann muss uns das allen große Sorgen machen.
Weil man nur noch dem Hype hinterher läuft, ohne...
Sehr stark politisch besetzt. Extremst unterfinanziert. Und kein gesunder Zustand und auch ein System, in dem natürlich auch Menschen aufgeben, weil sie sagen, seit 20 Jahren arbeite ich produktiv an dieser Frage und alle Leute kennen mich, ich habe wichtige Beiträge geleistet, aber ich kriege jetzt einfach konsistent nichts mehr gefördert. Was bedeutet, gestern hat der Dekan an meine Tür geklopft und hat gesagt, also der Strom für deinen Kühlschrank, wenn du den noch privat bezahlst, dann kannst du ihn behalten, aber den Raum nehme ich dir weg. Und im Kühlschrank sind die Präparate der letzten zehn Jahre drin, das sind die Zustände. Das ist nicht Uganda. Das ist Oregon, das ist Washington, das ist Los Angeles. Und das macht mir Sorgen.
Jetzt hatten Sie ja gesagt, ein Drittel der Anträge sind schlecht. Was macht die schlecht, ist das die wissenschaftliche Arbeit, die dann nicht interessant ist oder ist es einfach nur der Antrag der schlecht ist, also ist das schlecht formuliert?
Ist natürlich alles.
Also ist es ein Kommunikationsproblem, meine ich?
Manchmal ist es so, ich habe das Problem A in 26 Varianten schon erforscht, jetzt möchte ich die 27. Variante ausprobieren. Dann mangelt es dann irgendwie auch an Kreativität. Ich möchte es mal so platt sagen. Oder Leute sagen, ich möchte das und das untersuchen, sie können aber nicht nachweisen, dass sie das untersuchen können. Dass sie Erfahrungen haben darin, sie sind Experten in einem ganz anderen Bereich. Oder sie haben es so konfus geschrieben, dass man es nicht richtig versteht. Oder sie haben es eigentlich verständlich geschrieben, aber sie haben es leider zu verständlich geschrieben und so, dass man versteht, dass sie es nicht verstanden haben. Und all das kann passieren. Von groben Schnitzern bis hin zu einfach ein bisschen dümmlich, das kann alles sein. Also die ganze Palette des menschlichen und keiner ist wirklich davor gefeit. Meine Anträge sind auch schon abgelehnt worden. Und ich habe auch böse Kommentare gekriegt und sicherlich haben meine Gutachter Kollegen auch gedacht, naja der Onur war auch schon mal besser. Was hat er sich denn da gedacht. So etwas passiert. Und meine grobe Erfahrung ist, ein Drittel kann man getrost zur Seite legen und sagen, ja das...
Aber Anträge schreiben ist ja eigentlich so ein Sport, den man durchaus im Rahmen der Ausbildung auch mal ein wenig eintrainieren könnte.
Absolut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das in irgendeiner Form unterrichtet wird oder teilweise …
Es wird nicht unterrichtet, aber das ist meine Verantwortung, dass meine Leute schreiben Lernen, schreiben Lernen auch als Artikel. Schreiben Lernen als Antrag. Das ist der härteste Teil meiner Arbeit. Ich bekomme Manuskripte von jungen hoffnungsvollen Doktoranden, in einem grauenhaften Englisch und wo irgendwie die ganze Logik noch nicht so ganz stimmt und und dann sind es immer so die dunklen Momente, wo ich so denke, gib mir die Daten, ich schreibe dir das in drei Tagen vernünftig runter. Aber so dauert es zwei Monate. Und es ist für beide Seiten einfach nur hässlich. Aber es ist mein Job. Und das muss ich tun. Weil dieser Mensch muss es ja lernen. Ich denke immer noch an meinen Chef zurück, siebenmal musste ich meinen Artikel in Deutsch schreiben, bis er sagte, jetzt darfst du ihn auf Englisch übersetzen. Weil jetzt ist die Logik zumindest schon mal halbwegs da. Der arme Mann hat so gelitten. So war das.
Aber das übt dann auch.
Das übt auch. Ja.
Ja ganz so schlecht gewirkt haben kann das ja alles nicht. Ich habe es bisher noch nicht erwähnt, will das aber jetzt noch einmal tun. Dieses Jahr ist ja auch ein Preis an Sie gegangen, ausgegeben von der eben schon erwähnten Forschungsgemeinschaft, dem Stifterverband gemeinsam, der Communicator Preis. Ich habe jetzt die Laudatio nicht gelesen, was die ursprüngliche, was der eigentliche tiefere Grund war. Wir haben ja über vieles hier schon gesprochen. Aber ich denke, was auf jeden Fall eine wichtige Rolle spielt, ist ja die Kommunikation in die Öffentlichkeit. Wir sind ja schon ein paar Mal daran angestoßen an diesem Themenbereich. Aber ich denke hier, bisher haben wir auch wirklich viel Kommunikation innerhalb des Wissenschaftssystems, um die eigenen Ziele zu fördern, um überhaupt sich erst mal zu vernetzen, um Geld zu bekommen, um Anträge durch zu bekommen. Und die wissenschaftliche Arbeit als solche zu organisieren. Wenn man jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit geht, und die Motivation, warum man das tun möchte, haben wir ja schon ansatzweise gesprochen, also diese Verpflichtung, dass man eben einfach auch die Notwenigkeit erachtet, von der Gesellschaft finanzierte Arbeit auch nach außen hin zu erklären, zu legitimieren, überhaupt ein bisschen in die Breite zu tragen. War das bei Ihnen von Anfang an schon ein Thema oder ist das etwas, was sich erst so mit der Zeit entwickelt?
Also zumindest bei mir hat es sich mit der Zeit entwickelt. Ganz am Anfang ist man ja ein ziemlicher Nobody und selbstverständlich kommt kein Redakteur vorbei. Und gibt es irgendwann so diesen Moment, ich hatte mal den Gerhard-Hess-Preis gekriegt, da weiß ich noch genau, da kam ein Redakteur vorbei, fand mich aber nicht im Labor und ist dann wortlos wieder weggegangen. Und das hat mich unglaublich geärgert, weil das wäre das erste Mal in meinem Leben gewesen, dass ich mit einem Redakteur über meine Forschung hätte sprechen können. Tagelang habe ich noch überlegt, wieso war ich genau dann in der Bibliothek, gibt es eine Möglichkeit rauszubekommen, ihm mitzuteilen, dass ich jetzt wieder im Labor bin und er solle doch bitte mit mir sprechen usw.
Gerhard-Hess-Preis ist für Nachwuchswissenschaftler von der DFG.
Genau. Und solche Dinge passieren halt am Anfang und dann kommen so die ersten Leute und da macht man halt die ganzen blutigen Fehler. Als da sind, dass man mit den falschen Leuten auf die falsche Art und Weise redet. Und die ganze Palette von Medien, die es gibt von den sehr preiswerten Medien bis hin zu den Qualitätsmedien, dass man die dann lernt halbwegs zu unterscheiden. Und das nimmt dann so seinen eigenen Lauf. Und ich mache eine Forschung, die die Menschen aus verschiedenen Gründen, die ich nicht immer ganz verstehe, weil ich finde die sowieso total spannend, aber warum sie sich gerade für meine Forschung interessieren, finde ich schön und das finden viele Leute offensichtlich interessant genug, dass viele journalistische Nachfragen kommen. Und ich habe dann halt das Privileg, mir das auch ein bisschen aussuchen zu können und das genieße ich.
Aber reagiert man dann eigentlich nur noch auf die Nachfragen oder gibt es auch so ein proaktives Öffentlichkeitsding?
Nein eigentlich nicht. Also bei mir gibt es sicherlich nichts proaktives. Das soll jetzt nicht komisch klingen, aber es gibt so viele Anfragen, dass ich an das Proaktive jetzt gar nicht so gedacht habe.
O. k., also das ist jetzt schon eher so ein Luxusproblem dann.
Ja genau. So ist das. Wenn ich irgendwie etwas ganz ganz dringendes hätte, wo ich denke, unbedingt muss das in den Zeitungen drin stehen, weiß ich nicht, was ich dann machen würde, aber bisher war es noch nicht so.
Aber wir haben schon angesprochen, so Sachen wie der Klimadiskurs, wo es auch extreme Widerstände gibt, teilweise aus der Gesellschaft, teilweise aus der Industrie, teilweise auch aus anderen politischen Kreisen. Wo sich auch die Wissenschaftler selber so bisschen auch in der Situation gesehen haben, irgendwie reicht es nicht, dass wir das jetzt für uns zusammengetragen haben, also normalerweise ist ja im Prinzip der Durchbruch für die eigene Arbeit, in dem Moment da, wo man die Anerkennung der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft hat. So die finden jetzt alle mein Paper toll und es wird fleißig zitiert, und irgendwie alle sind davon überzeugt, dass ich mal total Recht gehabt habe. Alles ist super, ich kann in Urlaub gehen oder in Rente oder was auch immer. Aber in dem Moment, wo man dann eben auch quasi erwartet, dass die wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse jetzt mehr sind, als nur seine Grundlagenerkenntnis. Sozusagen, also hier guck mal, wir haben uns das jetzt mal angeschaut und da rauscht gerade irgendwie so eine Welle auf uns zu. Da hat sich so ein Tsunami zusammengebraut, oder bildlich gesprochen, wir stehen am Ufer und das Wasser zieht sich zurück. Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Situation. Wo man sagt, hier Überschwemmungen, und alle gucken hin und sagen, wieso Überschwemmung, das Wasser verschwindet ja. Bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich neben dieser Klimasituation jetzt noch ein zweites Beispiel finden könnte, aber auch hier muss man ja im Prinzip raus aus der Kammer und auch mal ganz andere Bereiche ansprechen. Man muss die Gesellschaft ansprechen, man muss auch die Politik ansprechen.
Das ist bei mir zum Beispiel die Tierversuchsdebatte. Das ist das Äquivalent dazu. Das ist natürlich dann, man macht sich natürlich wesentlich weniger Freunde damit, dass man als Klimaforscher die Industrie gegen sich hat, ist ja dann irgendwie eine Medaille wert, man ist ja sozusagen das kleine gallische Dorf und dabei ist das wesentlich mehr, als ein kleines gallisches Dorf. Aber man hat die positiven Aspekt auf seiner Seite. In unserem Bereich sind es eben die Tierversuchsdebatte. Die sehr viel härter ausgetragen wird, und wo ich mich dann als Mitglied der Community, der wissenschaftlichen Community auch dann in der Verpflichtung sehe, auch nach außen zu gehen. Und das zu erklären, das zu erläutern. Mich nicht zu verstecken. Und, und auch das ist wichtig, mit Kollegen solidarisch zu sein, und das auch offen solidarisch zu sein. Die im Moment öffentlich an den Pranger gestellt werden. Und wenn ich das als Beispiel mal geben darf, das hatten wir vor kurzem, es gab ja diese Kampagne einer Tierversuchsgegnergruppe, gegen Andreas Kreiter, das ist ein Kollege, der arbeitet elektrophysiologisch mit Affen in Bremen. Die Stadt Bremen, die Tierschutzorganisation, als auch die Stadt Bremen, haben ja jahrelang gegen ihn prozessiert und haben sozusagen gegen seine Versuche prozessiert und er hat dann höchstrichterlich, vor dem höchsten Verwaltungsgericht, sind sie dann gescheitert. Und das war eine riesige Niederlage für die Stadt Bremen und das war sozusagen ein Populismus, der nach hinten losgegangen ist. Daraufhin ist jetzt eine ganzseitige Anzeige mit einem großen Bild von ihm erschienen, in dem unter anderem der Einführungssatz war, Tierexperimentatoren sollte man nicht leichtfertig für Menschen halten. Diese ganzseitige Anzeige ist zum Beispiel in der Zeit erschienen, in der Wissensredaktion. Ist in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen erschien, ist im Weser Kurier erschienen usw. Zeitgleich habe ich mit einem der Chefredakteure des Wissensbereich der Zeit über ein mögliches gemeinsames Projekt diskutiert und ich mache diese Zeit auf und lese diese Anzeige im Wissensteil, dann habe ich ihm gesagt, tut mir leid, dass ist nicht das Medium. Wir haben dann blitzschnell uns eben zusammen telefoniert, die Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft, die Akademie der Wissenschaften usw. und so fort, hat sich dann eben an diese großen Zeitungen gewandt und sie zu Recht gefragt, wie es kommt, dass sie eine ganzseitige Anzeige als Kampagne gegen ein Individuum annehmen, für Geld, das gleichzeitig auch noch im Titel trägt, dass ihm das Mensch sein und einer ganzen Gruppe von Menschen das Menschsein abgesprochen wird. Und ich möchte eines dazu sagen, man kann absolut auch sehr kontrovers über Tierversuche reden und jeder ist absolut frei dagegen zu sein. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir darüber reden sollten, dass wir Menschen Menschen sind und Menschenrechte haben. Und das Wissenschaftler natürlich auch Sicherheit ihres Lebens haben müssen usw. und so fort. Naja und das sind so Momente, wo man dann eben aus seinem Häuschen raus muss, dann muss man sich dann mit seinem Kollegen solidarisieren, da muss man Leute anrufen, da muss man auf der Straße stehen und das habe ich dann noch mehrfach gemacht. Ich bin häufig zu Tierversuchgegnern diesen Ständen gegangen, wo dann irgendwie von meinen ganzen Kollegen, die mit Ratten, Katzen, Hunden, Affen gearbeitet haben, wo dann deren Privatnummern drauf standen, dass man die nachts anruft, und so und dann habe ich gesagt, warum führt ihr mich dort nicht auf? Ich habe mich dann an die Stände gestellt und dann jeden, der dann von denen beraten wurde, gegen beraten. Das ist mir ein Anliegen, weil ich mache Tierversuche und ich mache Tierversuche mit allen gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen und Vorschriften und ich versuche sie in der ethisch einwandfreiesten Art und Weise zu machen. Aber dann glaube ich, gehört zu meiner Arbeit auch die Aufgabe, mich dann am Samstagmorgen zur Not irgendwo in die Fußgängerzone zu stellen und mich daneben an einen Stand zu stellen und schaut her, ich bin einer von den Leuten, die auf der Liste stehen und ich möchte, dass ihr auch mit mir redet, ihr soll diese Gegenposition auch hören. Und wenn ihr mich dann nachts um drei terrorisiert, so be it. Das gehört einfach dazu. Das gehört zu diesem Leben in dieser Gesellschaft dazu und an der Stelle sehe ich mich ein bisschen, wenn Sie so wollen, politisch in der Verantwortung.
Aber ich meine das ist doch ein relativ krasses, aber auch ein gut nachvollziehbares Beispiel, wo dieser Kontakt zur Öffentlichkeit, woraus ich ableiten würde, es ist auch wichtig, diesen Kontakt zur Öffentlichkeit frühzeitig und auch permanent wiederkehrend zumindest zu versuchen.
Exakt. Niemals verstecken. Niemals verstecken und so tun, als würde man dieses oder jenes nicht machen. Das ist die falsche Politik. Den Menschen ist die Wahrheit zuzumuten, wie Ingeborg Bachmann mal so schön gesagt hat. Den Menschen ist die Wahrheit zuzumuten. Wenn ich will, dass ich das Denken verstehe, wenn ich will, dass ich mein Gehirn verstehe, mit allem, was auch eventuell pathologisch damit in Zusammenhang steht, dann darf ich den Menschen nicht erzählen, das sind alles Computermodelle oder das sind Zellkulturen, das ist einfach gelogen. Weil ich kann es nicht mit Zellkulturen machen, ich kann es nicht mit Computermodellen machen. Und das ist der Preis, den wir auch als Gesellschaft dafür bezahlen müssen, und wir sollten transparent und ehrlich sein, jeder von uns. Und natürlich auch der Mann auf der Straße, der berühmte, der sich darüber informieren möchte.
Wenn man jetzt so die Öffentlichkeit sucht, dann kann man das ja entweder machen, in dem man halt zu “den Medien“ geht, oder im Idealfall kommen sie halt auch irgendwie selber gleich vorbei. Ich denke mal, da gibt es auch sehr unterschiedliche Erfahrungen, weil es ja auch sehr bekannt ist, dass zumindest Teile der Medienlandschaft häufig, wie soll ich sagen, die Geschichten im Prinzip schon fertig geschrieben haben, bevor sie überhaupt das erste Gespräch darüber führen. Das sind dann so die schlechten Beispiele, andererseits gibt es ja auch eine sehr aufgeweckte wissenschaftliche Medienlandschaft...
Darf ich ganz kurz ein Beispiel bringen. Die TAZ Bremen hat mal ein Interview mit mir erfunden.
Erfunden?
Erfunden, genau. Das fand ich großartig. Die hat mal ein Interview mit mir abgedruckt, was ich nie geführt habe. Die sind halt einfach ins Netz gegangen, haben ganz viele Sätze von mir genommen und haben darum dann Fragen gebastelt. Und so entstand ein Interview mit mir, das fand ich großartig.
Das ist sehr gewagt. Wie reagiert man darauf?
Da jetzt nichts Schlimmes drin statt, sondern es war einfach nur ein unglaublich langweiliges Interview, so dass man sich ernsthaft fragt, warum macht ein Mensch sich die Mühe, ein langweiliges Interview zu erfinden.
Wo man auch ein spannendes hätte selber führen können.
Exakt, genau. Die wollten ein Interview mit mir haben, und ich hatte ewig keine Zeit. Und die fanden unbedingt, das müsste jetzt sein, dann habe ich mich eben an sie gewandt, ob das ihr journalistisches Selbstverständnis wäre und die sagten, nein das würden sie auch normalerweise nicht sagen, aber jetzt hat es mal sein müssen. Ich weiß es nicht, ich krieg es nicht mehr so genau hin. Also ab und zu passieren solche Sachen. In diesem Falle ja lustig.
Obwohl die TAZ nicht unbedingt gerade für solche...
TAZ Bremen, vielleicht ist TAZ Bremen...
Ja, wir wissen es nicht. Was braucht denn die Öffentlichkeit?
Transparentes Wissen über das was passiert. Also wieder runter gekocht, sodass es verständlich ist, frei von irgendwelchen ornamenthaften Fremdworten. Der Kern erklärt aber auch als Geschichte erklärt, eingebettet in einen Werdens- und in einen Geschichtsprozess, dann aber auch transparent bezüglich der Methoden und Mittel. Wir hatten gerade über Tierversuche gesprochen, Transparenz darüber, was das kostet. Und zwar kostet in vielerlei Hinsicht, das kostet Geld, das kostet Stellen. Aber es kostet vielleicht auch 50 Ratten das Leben. Diese Transparenz müssen wir herstellen. Damit die Menschen wissen, das ist sozusagen das Wissensprodukt, das ist dort erstellt worden und ich finde das Klasse, das finde ich total spannend, absolut faszinierend. Und dafür bin ich bereit, diesen Preis zu bezahlen oder aber auch, ich bin nicht bereit, diesen Preis zu bezahlen. Da ist ja jeder anderer Meinung. Aber diese Transparenz muss vermittelt werden. Aber es darf eben dann nicht irgendwie, das und das ist raus gekommen, sondern es muss eine Geschichte sein. Es muss eine Geschichte sein, in der dieses Wissensprodukt eingebet ist, sodass man dann in dieser Geschichte erkennt, dass es ein Vorher gab. Und dass es ein Jetzt gab. Und eventuell wird es soundso weitergehen.
Es gibt ein ganz fundamentales Problem, dass glaube ich keiner von uns vernünftig gelöst hat. Und das ist die Erklärung dessen, was Grundlagenforschung ist und was angewandte Forschung ist und wie sie zusammenhängen. Es gibt da glaube ich ein sehr weit verbreitetes Missverständnis, indem man sagt, die angewandte Forschung, das ist die Forschung die wir brauchen, und da nehmen wir nur das, was wir wirklich für den direkten Anwendungsbezug brauchen. Und alles andere ist Neugierforschung, auf die können wir verzichten. Die Neugierforschung ist irgendwie ein schlechtes Wort offensichtlich. Neugierig sein darf man privat, aber dann nicht mit öffentlichen Mitteln und schon gar nicht unter Aufopferung von Tieren oder irgendwelchen anderen...
Oder ab 18.
Ab18, genau. Neugierig sein ist irgendwie schlecht. Und natürlich weiß jeder, der ein bisschen in dem Wissenschaftsbereich reinschaut, das ganz am Anfang Wissenschaft immer in einem Nebel rumforscht. Indem man eine lokale Frage hat, die man versucht, zu beantworten. Und man sieht irgendwie nur diesen einen Knoten und je mehr sich das aufhält, desto mehr damit verwandte Knoten erkennt man und dann findet man diesen und den nächsten verbundenen Knoten dann interessant und irgendwann für so ganz kurze Momente, verzieht sich der Nebel und man sieht, ach das könnte da und dahin gehen. Aber das ist am Anfang häufig gar nicht hundertprozentig klar. Aus der Anwendungsperspektive wiederum betrachtet ist es so, man braucht verlässliche Daten, um irgendeinen Anwendungsforschungbezug herzustellen. Diese verlässlichen Daten kommen alle aus dieser Grundlagenforschung. Wie funktioniert dieser Knoten, wie ist er mit dem nächsten verbunden, wie ist er mit dem Dritten verbunden, wieso funktioniert der dritte Knoten anders als der erste Knoten. All das ist Grundlagenforschung, neugiergetriebene Grundlagenforschung gewesen, in der Menschen, die an diesem dritten Knoten geforscht haben, noch gar nicht wirklich wussten, dass das mal eine relevante Frage werden würde. Und es ist halt eine Investition ins Ungewisse, weil wir wissen einfach nicht, wie diese verschiedenen Dinge miteinander verwoben sind und es ist immer denkbar, dass ein Teil der Grundlagenforschung interessante Erkenntnisse zutage fördert, aber sonst schlicht und einfach nichts. Aber es ist nicht vorhersagbar, wie die Dinge zusammenhängen. Und das glaube ich, diesen Prozess verständlich zu machen, der ist keinem von uns besonders gut gelungen. Verrückterweise finde ich die beste Art der Beschreibung dessen, von einem der Apple Gründer, Moment wie heißt der nochmal, der gerade an Krebs...
Steve Jobs.
Steve Jobs. Steve Jobs hat ja an einer Akademiefeier, ich glaube in Stanford war das, diesen wunderbaren Vortrag mit den Connecting the Dots gehalten. Und dort beschrieb er ja, dass er sich dann eingeschrieben hat an einer Universität, seine Eltern waren keine Akademiker, er war ein adoptiertes Kind, sie hatten seiner leiblichen Mutter versprechen müssen, dass sie alles investieren, damit dieses Kind später mal an die Uni geht, dann nur durften sie ihn adoptieren. Die haben also fleißig gespart, sie haben ihn auf irgendeine Uni geschickt, die viel zu teuer war, mit der er nicht klar kam, er hat in kürzester Zeit die gesamten Ersparnisse seiner Eltern vernichtet und hat aber keinen Abschluss geschafft. Und weil er sich dann nicht mehr nach Hause traute, fing er an, dort Kurse zu besuchen. Unter anderem in Kalligraphie. Und er fing dann an, all das zu lernen, was später den Apple ausmachte. Gutes Design, Lesbarkeit, klare Linien, und das hat er alles dort gelernt. In dem Moment, in dem er das lernte, war er natürlich Äonen davon entfernt, eine Computerfirma gründen. Im Nachhinein macht sein ganzes Leben sind. Nach vorne gelebt sind es zufällige Konnektivitäten gewesen, die dann glücklich sich zusammengefügt haben. Und dieses Bild hat Steve Jobs aus meiner Sicht in einer Klarheit und in einer Präzision und auf kurze Art und Weise so erläutert, wie ich es irgendwie nie richtig hingekriegt habe in meinem Leben und eigentlich ist es das, was wir auch erreichen müssten. Indem wir unsere eigene Geschichte zurück gehen, die Geschichte einer erfolgreichen Anwendung zurückgehen und sagen, so hat es begonnen, so dick war der Nebel. Damals, als dieser brasilianische Wissenschaftler, die und die Experimente gedacht hat, das war nur Neugier getrieben. Später wurde das wichtig.
Ja, Steve Jobs ist sicherlich auch einer derjenigen, der auch vor allem durch seine Kommunikation nach außen eine ganze Menge verändert hat. Weil er eben auch in der Lage war, nicht nur diese Dinge anzureißen und irgendwie Strukturen herzustellen und Leute zusammenzubringen, sondern dass dann auch noch zu vermitteln auf so eine bestimmte Art und Weise. Den Computer als das Fahrrad für das Hirn zu bezeichnen, das ist einfach ein Bild, wenn man das einmal gehört hat, das geht so schnell gar nicht wieder raus. Ich denke, dass sind in gewisser Hinsicht auch gerade Anekdoten und auch die konkreten Geschichten dieser Wissenschaftler vielleicht auch ein Vehikel über die es ganz gut funktioniert, wenn man es nicht allgemein erklären kann, dass man es eigentlich immer wieder auch an diesem Beispiel festmacht. Ich selbst erinnere mich jetzt gerade, dass ist vielleicht nicht das allerbeste Beispiel, was das Ziel angeht, aber es waren Japaner, die den blauen Laser erfunden haben, die gerade den Nobelpreis bekommen haben. Die waren insofern sehr angewandt in ihrer Forschung, als dass sie explizit diesen blauen Laser erzeugen wollten, aber partout eben einfach keinen Weg gefunden haben, dieses Schaltverhalten hinzubekommen. Immer wieder das Elektronenmikroskop herbeigeholt haben, um sich das anzuschauen. Was ist denn da falsch? Und was haben wir denn übersehen? Dann ging es halt irgendwann mal. Bis sie dann irgendwann mal festgestellt haben, dass gerade dieses betrachten des Objekts, dieser Elektronenbeschuss, genau der Prozess war, der letzten Endes zum Erfolg führte. Auch selbst, wenn es jetzt nicht freie Neugierforschung war, zeigt es doch sehr schön, dass der Prozess selber manchmal sich überhaupt gar nicht so sehr steuern lässt, sondern dass man einfach mal dem Zufall auch Raum lassen muss, um einfach zu Ergebnissen zu kommen, selbst wenn man am Anfang auch schon ein klares Ziel hatte. Sehr häufig sind ja solche Forschungen dann auch, was weiß ich, das eigentliche Ziel wurde häufig vollkommen verfehlt, aber man traf auf irgendetwas ganz anderes, was man so überhaupt nicht im Sinn hatte, was noch viel toller war oder zumindest wichtig genug. Und das zu kommunizieren, denke ich, ist sehr wichtig. Was haben Sie denn so an Feedback bekommen. Ich meine, so in die Öffentlichkeit, über Medien zu kommunizieren, das ist ja das eine, aber letzten Endes muss sich ja glaube ich auch eine Kommunikation daran messen lassen, was sie nun letzten Endes wirklich bewirkt. Da frage ich mich natürlich, wie quantifiziert man oder wie qualifiziert man auch das Feedback, dass man weiß, okay meine Kommunikation kommt auch an?
Also Universitätsalltag sind es natürlich in der Regel die Studenten, die dann eine sehr direkte, teilweise vehemente Rückmeldung leisten. Die Vorlesung war gut und man bekommt, natürlich wird die Vorlesung evaluiert, und dann sind besonders interessant die Kommentare der Studenten. Und das ist ja letztendlich auch ein Einüben von Kommunikation, wenn man eine Vorlesung hält, sagen wir mal für Erstsemester, das sind ja praktisch Menschen, die von außen kommen. Und die haben ja noch gar nicht diesen Wissenschaftsjargon übernommen. Und wenn die dann sagen, das war wirklich klasse, das war verständlich oder aber auch, das und das habe ich gar nicht verstanden, da musste ich dann nochmal komplett alles neu lesen und so. Das sind Dinge, die dann eine Rückmeldung schon auf der inneruniversitären Ebene schaffen. Und dann gibt es natürlich dann auch also Zuspruch aus Leuten, die eine Sendung gehört haben oder so. Aber in der Regel ist das nicht unbedingt so, dass man da unbedingt ein feines Barometer an Rückmeldung bekommt. Außer dass dann Kollegen sagen, das war super, das war verständlich oder wir laden dich mal da und dazu ein, da kommen nämlich die Bürger der Stadt X und du bist ja dafür geeignet, das vernünftig zu vermitteln. Das sind so Rückmeldungen, bei denen ich so das Gefühl habe, so ganz schlecht kann es nicht laufen.
Wenn man jetzt das Internet nimmt als, ich bezeichne es immer gerne als, das Universalmedium, über das man sozusagen alles senden kann. Unter anderem ja auch diesen Podcast. Dann ermöglicht es ja auch, sich selbst quasi zu einem Medienhaus zu machen. Um es vielleicht gleich mal ein bisschen überspitzt zu formulieren. Anfangs erwähnten Sie ja auch schon so, man muss als Wissenschaftler auch darüber nachdenken, ich weiß nicht, wie die Formulierung war, quasi so seine eigene Marke zu sein. Kurz gesagt. Also sich selber quasi so als eigenes, sein eigenes Produkt zu verstehen, und darüber eben dann auch über den Namen oder das Institut oder was auch immer man da jetzt für Begriffe ins Feld führt, darüber eben auch eine Identifikation mit der eigenen Arbeit zu erzielen. Da kann das Netz ja sehr wohl hilfreich sein, weil man eben diese ganzen Mittler nicht mehr hat. Da muss dann nicht eine Zeitung gedruckt werden, ein Journal postuliert werden, bei Veröffentlichung von Publikation hatten wir das auch schon. Aber auch was natürlich jetzt die direkte Öffentlichkeitsansprache betrifft, wäre das ja schon ein Weg. Jetzt ist es vielleicht nicht so die primäre Tätigkeit. Wichtig sein kann es aber schon, ich weiß nicht, welche... so ein Onur Güntürkün gibt es noch nicht, wo…?
Nein um Gottes Willen. Nein.
Kann ja passieren.
Nein, ich hoffe nicht. Also ich bin mir sicher, nicht. Ich bin Wissenschaftler und mein wichtigstes ist, Zeit für Forschung zu haben, und auch Zeit zum Denken zu haben. Deshalb bin ich in Berlin im Wissenschaftskolleg, das funktioniert ein bisschen so wie ein Kloster, man ist eingeschlossen und man geht dann nur selten raus. Ich bin jetzt hier bei Ihnen im Studio, aber das ist einige der wenigen Male, dass ich aus diesem Kloster herausgehe. Ansonsten bewege ich mich nur innerhalb dieses Klosters und das ist gut so. Jeder von uns hat nur 24 Stunden und ein Zeitvertrag mit dem Leben. Das bedeutet, man muss sich irgendwie überlegen, wie man seine Zeit am besten aufteilt. Wir hatten ja schon mehrfach darüber gesprochen, dass Kommunikation nach außen wichtig ist, aber Kommunikation nach außen ist ja kein Selbstzweck. Sondern es ist ein Zweck. Und insofern muss dieser Zweck dann natürlich auch eine zeitliche Limitierung haben. Denn ich sehe mich jetzt nicht als Unterhalter, sondern ich sehe mich als Wissenschaftler. Und ich möchte Probleme lösen, tiefe Probleme, Probleme, die ich sehr tief finde, die in der Regel so abstrus sind, dass es nur zwölf andere Menschen auf der Welt gibt, die sie auch spannend.. Aber für mich sind sie unglaublich spannend. Und die möchte ich gerne lösen. Aber zu diesem Zweck, dass Menschen das Recht haben, meine Arbeit auch nachvollziehen zu können, sind Medien eben sehr gut und dann suche ich diesen Kontakt oder nehme den Kontakt sehr gerne auch wahr. Aber nicht sozusagen als etwas, bei dem ich sagen muss, wir müssen nach außen, wir müssen viel mehr machen Leute in meinem Labor, das eigentlich nicht.
Aber amerikanische Universitäten sind da ja teilweise auch schon sehr weit, zumindest die privaten großen, sehr weit vorangeschritten, dass komplette Vorlesungsreihen im Netz veröffentlicht werden, dass man fast schon gar nicht mehr hingehen muss. Wenn man sich also nur die Inhalte erarbeiten möchte über Vorlesungen und so, kann man in seinem eigenen kleinen Heimkloster auch sitzen bleiben, hat zumindest ähnliche Möglichkeiten, es fehlt immer noch das Networking etc. und die Leute, dass ist ganz klar, aber das ist eigentlich auch ein interessanter Weg, dass man als Institution diese Öffentlichkeit sucht.
Auch meine Universität hat natürlich eine Presseabteilung und diese Presseabteilung freut sich über jede Meldung, über irgendetwas was an unserer Uni passiert, was gut ist und was nach außen dringt. Und sucht natürlich dann auch irgendwie den Kontakt mit den Medien und bringt Wissenschaftler dann da rein und berichtet über diese Dinge. Es ist klar, dass ist deren Beruf. Und ich als Mitglied der Universität bin solidarisch mit meiner Universität und mach dann in der Regel auch mit. Das hält sich alles in einem Rahmen, in dem ich eigentlich noch sehr gut meine Hauptaufgaben auch erledigen könnte. Ich hätte jetzt keine Onur Güntürkün Sendung einmal die Woche, da würde ich mir die Kugel geben.. Nein also das nicht.
Vielleicht einmal im Monat. Vielleicht so als letzter Punkt, das ist jetzt ein bisschen Kommunikation noch ein bisschen weiter gedacht, gerade so, wo Sie meinten, ja ich komme ja nicht raus aus meinem Kloster, internationaler Austausch findet auf Konferenzen statt, findet aber auch dadurch statt, dass man Forschungssemester angeht. Vielleicht gibt es dazu noch ein paar Empfehlungen, vielleicht haben Sie selber schon mal welche gemacht, waren Sie da irgendwie im Ausland oder einfach nur die Zeitung gelesen?
Genau genommen bin ich ja die ganze Zeit im Ausland. Aber um das richtige Ausland nochmal zu benennen, klar ich war eine Weile in den Staaten, in Belgien, in Australien, in der Türkei auch als Wissenschaftler ein halbes Jahr, habe an einem Projekt gearbeitet. Bin viel unterwegs, also wenn man diese vier Wochen Aufenthalte nimmt, dann kommen eine ganze Menge an Ländern und Kontinenten zusammen. Aber ich würde Ihnen widersprechen, dass der Austausch auf Konferenzen oder auf Auslandssemestern stattfindet. Erstmal ist eine Universität natürlich immer ein Bienenschwarm, mit einem Bienenschwarm von Besuchern gleichzusetzen. Ununterbrochen kommen Menschen von außen, sind dann einen Tag da, zwei Tage da, drei Tage da und man selbst ist ja selbst auch irgendwo. Das ist Punkt 1. Punkt 2, das Internet, das hochgelobte, ist ein fantastisches Medium. Ich habe die ganze Skype offen und dann macht es plötzlich tüdelüt und mein Kollege aus, was weiß ich, Florida meldet sich. Oder mein Kollege aus Japan meldet sich und dann quatschen wir einfach 5 Minuten und da wir irgendwie alte Kumpels sind reden wir natürlich über Forschung, aber dann natürlich auch, wie es denn der Frau geht und ob der Hund immer noch hinkt usw. und so fort. D.h. man ist ein Mausklick von seinen Freunden im Rest der Welt entfernt. Und das ist eine sehr eng verwobene Welt, in der die Menschen eigentlich im Schnitt ziemlich gut zueinander sind. Und im Schnitt eigentlich sehr freundlich miteinander umgehen. Und es ist so ein bisschen, mir kommt es häufig so vor, wie Sportler, die Kameraden sind, aber nur einer kann die Goldmedaille gewinnen. Aber das bedeutet nicht, dass der Kamerad der Feind ist oder so, manchmal muss man zusammenarbeiten und in der Regel arbeitet man häufig zusammen und manchmal gerät man in Situationen, wo man wirklich in einem Wettbewerb ist, ich habe es in meinem Leben praktisch nie erlebt, dass es richtig böse wurde. Nun arbeite ich vielleicht in Bereichen, wo das ganz große Geld nicht ist oder so etwas oder der Nobelpreis winkt oder so etwas, aber das gibt es natürlich dann auch. Wo die Leute dann teilweise auch sehr bösartig miteinander umgehen. Ich habe es in meinem Leben Gott sei Dank kaum erlebt.
Ja und wie man in den Wald reinruft…
… So schallt es heraus.